Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und andere.
Kosmische Angelegenheiten.
Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle zur 119.
Ausgabe von Raumzeit.
Und ich habe mal ein bisschen nachgeblättert, wir gehen jetzt hier irgendwie schon ins 13. Jahr.
Die Sendung gibt es schon eine Weile. Und ja, gute Gelegenheit mal eine Sendung
zu machen, wo es auch darum geht, ein wenig in die Vergangenheit zu schauen,
aber auch in die Zukunft,
denn heute bin ich nach Bonn gefahren zur Raumfahrtagentur des DLR und ja,
ich begrüße erstmal meinen Gesprächspartner für heute, Dennis Regenbrecht. Hallo Dennis.
Schönen guten Morgen Tim.
Ja, die Raumfahrtagentur, die benennt sich auch ab und zu mal ein bisschen um, oder?
Ja, wir haben schon einige Namen hinter uns.
Was denn so?
Also ganz früher gab es mal die Deutsche Agentur für Raumfahrtangelegenheiten,
das waren die 90er Jahre, da waren wir tatsächlich nicht Teil des DLRs.
Dann wurden wir mit dem DLR-Verein namt, dann hießen wir auch Raumfahrtagentur im DLR,
dann wurde es als Raumfahrtmanagement umbezeichnet und jetzt sind wir wieder
seit, ich weiß gar nicht, seit wie vielen Jahren, zwei oder drei,
wieder Raumfahrtagentur.
Also Namen, ja okay, sind Schall und Rauch.
Die Aufgaben und die Arbeiten, die wir hier machen, die haben sich nicht verändert.
Also das ist eigentlich immer noch genau dasselbe wie früher.
Okay, gut. Bevor wir dann dazu vielleicht kommen, starten wir doch vielleicht mal mit dir.
Aber um es vielleicht nochmal gesagt zu haben, wir wollen heute sprechen über
die Ariane, über das Raketenprogramm Ariane, mit dem Still Air eine ganze Menge zu tun hat.
Aber es ist natürlich, wie alle wissen, ein gesamteuropäischer Kraftakt,
dieses Projekt seit Jahrzehnten voranzutreiben und da tut sich ja nun demnächst auch sehr viel.
Wie bist du denn dazu gekommen?
Also wenn ich ganz zurückblicke, muss ich sagen, also ich habe mich als Kind
immer schon für Raumfahrt und gerade für Raketen begeistert.
Ich meine, also wirklich als Kind schon in der Schule und ich habe mich dann
auch entschlossen, später, als ich Abitur gemacht hatte, Luft- und Raumfahrttechnik
zu studieren und habe das dann auch getan.
Allerdings bei der Bundeswehr. Ich bin zwölf Jahre Offizier bei der Luftwaffe gewesen,
habe dann bei der Bundeswehr Uni Luft- und Raumfahrttechnik studiert und nach
zwölf Jahren, als dann meine Soldat auf Zeit abgelaufen war,
habe ich mich umgeschaut und dann war passenderweise, 2009 war das,
eine Stelle in der Raumfahrtagentur im Bereich Raketen frei geworden oder war ausgeschrieben.
Und da habe ich mir gedacht, okay, ich habe damals in Köln gewohnt,
das ist in Bonn, das ist noch viel besser, kannst im Rheinland bleiben,
ist ein geiler Job, bewirbst du dich drauf und dann wurde ich genommen.
Was hast du bei der Bundeswehr gemacht?
Ich war in den letzten Jahren, in den letzten vier Jahren, war ich bei der technischen
Betreuung Eurofighter in dem, was damals Waffensystemkommando hieß,
also technische Nutzerbetreuung, sage ich jetzt mal.
Und die Jahre vorher, wie das bei der Bundeswehr so üblich ist,
ist man so als Offizier alle zwei, drei Jahre ohnehin woanders.
Also ich war im Geschwader und in Amtstätigkeiten und wie gesagt,
die letzten Jahre halt Eurofighter auch als, ja, also Erfahrung gesammelt,
würde ich jetzt mal sagen, für die Ariane in europäischen Großprojekten.
Also das hat mir sicherlich nicht geschadet, da auch mit internationalen Partnern umgehen zu können.
Aber womit warst du damit beschäftigt? Also du bist jetzt nicht geflogen? Nein.
Ich bin nicht geflogen. Ich bin technischer Offizier. Das heißt,
ich bin dafür für die Technik verantwortlich.
Und in den Jahren, wo ich in dem Waffensystemkommando der Bundeswehr war,
bei der Luftwaffe, war ich spezifisch für die Antriebsanlage im Eurofighter.
Also alles, was auch zum Triebwerk gehört und drumherum verantwortlich.
Also du warst eh schon im Raketenbusiness sozusagen. Ja.
Ich habe auch Raumfahrttechnik vertieft und Raketen waren immer das, was ich machen wollte.
Deswegen ist es eigentlich richtig cool, dass es von den Kindesgedanken an ich
jetzt mit Mitte 40 immer noch in der Lage bin, das zu machen.
Okay, beneidenswert. Ja, dann bist du bei der Raumfahrtagentur gelandet.
Was ist hier dein offizieller Titel oder Aufgabenbeschreibung?
Ich bin dann, wie gesagt 2009 habe ich da angefangen, zwischendurch bin ich
dann auch mal aufgestiegen und so.
Was ich jetzt mache ist, ich bin Gruppenleiter und verantwortlich für den Bereich
Ariane, operationelle Träger und Infrastruktur.
Ist ein langer Name, ist ein langer Titel, ist aber faktisch alles,
was raketentechnisch fliegt und bald fliegt.
Also ich habe noch einen Kollegen, der ist auf meiner selben Ebene,
der ist für die ganzen Zukunftstätigkeiten verantwortlich und ich bin letzten
Endes verantwortlich für die großen Raketen, die schon fliegen oder bald fliegen.
Also alles, was Ariane ist und was als Infrastruktur und drumherum dazu gehört.
Und ist das so der primäre Kontaktpunkt Deutschlands zu dem Ariane-Projekt?
Kann man so sagen. Also das ist in Europa ja alles ein bisschen,
sag ich jetzt mal, schwieriger aufgebaut mit nicht so klaren Linien,
sondern das ist mehr so eine Art Netz.
Also wir, ich sag immer, wir sind so die Spinne im Netz.
Also wir sind auf der einen Seite Kontakt für die Industrie,
wir sind aber auch sozusagen der Einflusspunkt gegenüber der ESA,
aber gleichzeitig sind wir auch Dienstleister für das Ministerium.
Also Raumfahrt wird in Deutschland vom Wirtschaftsministerium durchgeführt und
wir sind als Agentur de facto eine nachgeordnete Behörde.
Wir sind es nicht der Jure, aber was wir machen ist eigentlich etwas,
was man auch als Raumfahrtbundesamt bezeichnen könnte.
Gibt es nicht, aber das was wir machen, wir sind also eine, es gibt da so ein,
das ist ein geiles deutsches Wort, ein spezielles Gesetz,
das nennt sich Raumfahrtaufgabenübertragungsgesetz, setzt, womit wir sozusagen
das Mandat haben für Deutschland in der Außenwahrnehmung in Raumfahrtsachen,
zu handeln. Und damit sind wir sozusagen de facto sowas wie eine Art Behörde,
auch wenn wir als Teil des DLRs eigentlich ein eingetragener Verein sind.
Okay, aber dann trifft ja der Name Agentur die Aufgabe eigentlich dann doch
schon sehr gut. Also ihr seid sozusagen so die Raumfahrtagenten.
Und wir vertreten dann halt auch die deutschen Interessen in der ESA.
Also ich bin nicht nur der Gruppenleiter hier, sondern ich bin auch ein Delegierter
in den ESA-Programmrat, in dem Raumtransportaktivitäten besprochen.
Mhm, okay. Also schon ein vielfältiges Aufgabengebiet, das sich hier kümmern
muss. Wie groß ist so der Technikanteil dann im Verhältnis zur Bürokratie?
Also bei mir ist der Technikanteil überschaubar. Also in der Position,
in der ich angefangen hatte, war es noch viel mehr.
Aber das, was ich mache, ist wirklich tatsächlich viel mehr Politik und Industriepolitik,
aber auch schauen, dass die Programme auch mit den internationalen Partnern
gemeinsam aufgestellt werden können.
Also das ist eher diplomatisch Politik und weniger, oh das Triebwerk funktioniert
nicht, was können wir da tun.
Also dafür gibt es halt dann auch die Leute in meinem Team.
Aber es hat jetzt nicht geschadet, dass du schon mal mit dem Schraubenschlüssel
am Triebwerk rumgefummelt hast?
Nee, und das ist halt auch bei uns Einstellungsvoraussetzung.
Also auch wenn das eine politische Geschichte hier ist und eine administrative
Geschichte, aber man muss halt auch wissen, dass einem die Partner nicht Quatsch erzählen.
Und als Ingenieur oder Physiker oder jemand anderes, der studiert hat,
also man braucht schon einen guten Bullshit-Detektor und das kommt halt nur,
indem man da auch mal gearbeitet hat und da die Erfahrung hat. Und.
Ich glaube, das geht auch in die andere Richtung, dass auch die Ingenieure sich
jetzt einfach von Leuten, die irgendwie keine Ahnung haben von der Materie,
jetzt auch nicht so gerne was sagen lassen.
Das ist schon so ein Ding, ich meine, das hat man ja ganz klassisch eigentlich
so in der Wirtschaft oft so. so.
Man wird so lange befördert, bis man nichts mehr bewirken kann und Inkompetenz
hilft da auf jeden Fall schon mal.
Den Eindruck habe ich so in der Raumfahrt nie so richtig gewonnen,
sondern es ist eigentlich,
auch wichtigere administrative und politische Posten sind oft mit Leuten besetzt,
die sehr viel Erfahrung haben, die als Astronauten gearbeitet haben,
die irgendwie lange Zeit auch hands-on an den Projekten und an den Missionen mitgearbeitet haben.
Einfach, weil es offensichtlich auch erforderlich ist, das zu haben?
Ich würde schon sagen, also wenn man sich jetzt die Hierarchie-Ebenen anguckt.
Ob jetzt bei Ariane Group oder bei anderen Firmen, auch OHB,
um jetzt nur Beispiele zu nennen, es ist schon so, dass auch auf den Führungsebenen
und auch als CEO teilweise Leute sind, die tatsächlich auch früher mal Projekte
gemacht haben und wissen, wie das funktioniert.
Und das ist, glaube ich, wie du schon gesagt hast.
Für das Eigenverständnis wichtig, aber auch die Akzeptanz der Ingenieure oder
der Mechaniker unten am Boden, in der Line.
Und natürlich mit einem gewissen Abstand entwickelt man natürlich auch andere Gedanken,
das ist auch klar, aber am Ende des Tages ist es immer noch gut,
seine Ingenieursfähigkeit im Kopf zu haben.
Und wie gesagt, das sieht man noch bei Airbus in den Führungsstrukturen.
Und das ist aber glaube ich wiederum was, was in Deutschland noch stärker vertreten
ist als vielleicht vergleichsweise in Frankreich.
Also da hat man schon ab einem bestimmten Level so die, sage ich jetzt mal,
Grand-École-Überflieger in Anführungsstrichen, die natürlich auch mal was Technisches
vielleicht gelernt haben, wenn sie auf der richtigen Grand-École waren.
Die aber schon von Anfang an klar wissen, okay, bei uns geht es ins obere Management.
Und da ist dann auch so tatsächlich so ein gewisser kultureller Unterschied
da zwischen wie Deutschland managt und wie Frankreich managt,
was gerade auch bei Ariane durchaus hin und wieder mal zu Reibungs,
also nicht Verlusten, aber Reibungsbomben führen kann.
Ja gut, ich meine, das macht ja die Isar auch aus, dass einfach die unterschiedlichsten
Kulturen da zusammenkommen.
Das mag manchmal ein Problem sein, aber es ist sicherlich an vielen Stellen auch ganz hilfreich.
Ja, also Monokulturen sind immer schädlich, finde ich.
Und je internationaler und je breiter man aufgestellt ist, desto mehr Ideen
haben auch die Chance verwirklicht zu werden.
Und das ist eigentlich auch das Schöne. Ich finde das geil,
in so einem multinationalen, kooperativen System unterwegs zu sein,
weil das ist eigentlich das, was Europa auszeichnet, meiner Meinung nach.
Und Ariane ist da auch ein ganz gutes Beispiel. Ich habe immer,
wenn ich da Vorträge vor interessierten Laien halte, habe ich da auch immer
mal ein schönes Beispiel,
dass Teile der Produktionsanlagen, in denen in Deutschland Ariane-Teile hergestellt
werden, in Bremen und in Frankreich, in die Myrona, nähe von Paris,
dass die beide eine Historie haben aus dem Zweiten Weltkrieg,
dass in diesen Hallen früher Flugzeuge gebaut wurden,
die sich gegenseitig bekämpft haben und das sind jetzt dieselben Hallen,
wo wir gemeinsam europäische Zukunft bauen und das ist, finde ich irgendwie
persönlich ein schönes Zeichen, gerade in der heutigen Zeit.
Ja, die ESA, wie so viele Europaprojekte, sind eigentlich im Kern Friedensprojekte
und von daher fühle ich das auch besser, wie sich das jetzt mittlerweile so entwickelt hat.
Mal gucken, wann man mit dem Rest der Welt dann nochmal auf ein ähnliches Footing kommt.
Ja, aber das gibt uns im Prinzip schon mal den richtigen Einstieg,
denn das ganze ESA oder sagen wir mal das ganze europäische Raumfahrtprojekt, das ist ja nicht nur ESA,
sondern das sind ja auch viele nationale Sachen, das ist auch die private Wirtschaft, die da dran hängt.
All das ist ja im Prinzip auch ein Kind der Nachkriegsordnung und der Erkenntnis,
dass es dann vielleicht doch für alle ein bisschen besser ist,
wenn man sich nicht die ganze Zeit mit Raketen beschießt, sondern vielleicht
die halt mal woanders hinschickt.
Das ist definitiv der bessere Weg.
Ich hatte hier in Raumzeit 98 mich mit Helmut Trischler unterhalten.
Da haben wir diese ganze Geschichte auch schon mal aufgerollt und da kam natürlich
dann auch schon die frühe Ariane-Geschichte so zum Tragen, weil sie auch so
einer der Schlüsselmomente eigentlich ist, der europäischen Raumfahrt.
Springen wir da vielleicht dann doch nochmal hin und das vielleicht auch noch
mit einem etwas technischeren Blick da drauf.
Es gab ja diese Europa-Rakete, die gebaut werden sollte.
Das war im Prinzip ja auch so ein bisschen der Katalysator, so ein bisschen dieser Beginn.
Wir können keine Raumfahrt machen, wenn wir nicht in der Lage sind,
irgendwas nach oben zu schicken.
Die Amerikaner und die Russen waren europaweit enteilt und das,
obwohl ja im Prinzip das alles mehr oder weniger auch aus Europa ursprünglich
mal kam, Wenn auch unter anderem Vorzeichen.
Wie war der Weg so aus deiner Perspektive, bis es dann zu diesem Ariane-Projekt kam?
Steinig. Also ich meine, du hast ja die Europa-Rakete angesprochen und das war
ja der erste Versuch schon Mitte der 60er Jahre, gemeinschaftlich europäisch
was auf die Beine zu stellen.
Es gab vorher schon Aktivitäten von UK, von Frankreich, national Raketen zu entwickeln.
Aber die Europa-Rakete und die dazugehörige Organisation, die ELDO,
die European Launchers Development Organization,
die waren der erste Versuch, gemeinsam was auf die Beine zu stellen,
was von der Idee her auch ganz gut war, von der Umsetzung.
Nicht ganz erfolgreich, wenn man das so sagen will.
Die Probleme, die man hatte, man hatte einige Fehlstarts in Folge und hat das
dann aufgegeben, aber die Grundproblematik war weniger das technische Unvermögen,
Kinderkrankheiten gibt es immer, sondern das war eher die Art und Weise,
wie das Projekt managementmäßig aufgesetzt wurde.
Also heutzutage gibt es ja System Engineering und wie man Requirements durchreicht
und diese ganzen Geschichten, wie das funktioniert,
das gab es damals in dieser Art eigentlich fast noch nicht und deswegen wurde
mehr oder weniger die, also ich vereinfache jetzt,
also alle die sich ein bisschen genau damit auskennen, bitte ich das zu entschuldigen,
wenn es jetzt zu vereinfacht ist, Aber die Raketenteile, die wurden so ein bisschen
verteilt wie so Lego-Bausteine.
Die Unterstufe, da hat man was genutzt, was die Briten schon hatten aus einer
interkonditionellen Teilrakete.
Dann hatten die Franzosen da was zusammengenommen, auch aus schon vorhandenen Raketenteilen.
Und die Deutschen, die sollten die Oberstufe machen und ich glaube,
die Italiener waren es, die sollten die Faring machen und dann hat man das dann
entwickelt und hat sich dann, also übertrieben gesagt,
irgendwann irgendwo getroffen, hat das zusammengeschraubt und hat gehofft,
dass das alles zusammen funktioniert.
Aber so eine Art, ich sage jetzt mal, Werner von Braun oder Sergej Koroljov
oder so eine Art übergeordnete Projektorganisation, die wirklich dafür sorgt, dass auch wirklich.
Kohärent zusammenpasst, die war eher unterdimensioniert und daher kam das dann auch.
Wahrscheinlich auch so ein bisschen so ein Zeichen auch für das noch nicht wirklich
hergestellte Vertrauen zwischen den Ländern und den Kulturen zu Beginn dieses ganzen Projektes.
Man muss dazu sagen, das war Mitte der 60er Jahre, das war 20 Jahre nach dem
Ende des Zweiten Weltkrieges.
Die Deutschen haben mitgemacht, dass die überhaupt mal wieder irgendwas bauen
durften, was irgendwie irgendwo hinfliegt.
Also das war auch ein Punkt, warum Deutschland die Oberstufe bekommen hat.
Man hat gesagt, die dürfen alles machen, oder dürfen nicht alles machen,
aber auf keinen Fall eine Unterstufe, die man später als Interkontinentalrakete nutzen kann.
Also Oberstufen, die nur dann funktionieren, wenn wir die irgendwie mit anderen
Sachen nach oben kriegen, alles gut, da können sie keinem mit beschießen,
aber alles andere so vorsichtig. Richtig.
Und das war wirklich der Grund, wie das damals aufgeteilt wurde.
Und interessanterweise diese Oberstufengeschichte, das ist das,
also Deutschland ist heutzutage immer noch in Europa das Oberstufenland.
Das kommt daher, das ist eigentlich auch strange. strange.
Und ja, also das Vertrauen war vielleicht noch nicht da.
Und wie gesagt, die Prozesse, die waren halt auch noch nicht so in so einer
Art kooperativen Art und Weise.
Also diese ganzen Großvorhaben, die gingen ja damals erst los.
Also ZERN wurde ja auch nach dem Krieg gegründet. Also diese ganze Art,
wie man europäisch zusammenarbeitet, das musste sich ja auch erst in irgendeiner
Art und Weise entwickeln.
Und hat sich dann da halt halt am Ende des Tages nicht so ganz positiv entwickelt.
Nach ein paar Jahren hat Frankreich gesagt, das ist jetzt irgendwie alles nicht so gut.
Und am Ende des Tages wurde das dann Anfang der 70er Jahre abgebrochen.
Und interessanterweise kam dann Frankreich, hat gesagt, okay, wir.
Europäische Kooperation ist gut, wir brauchen so eine Rakete.
Mit Europa hat es nicht geklappt, weil was daran lag, dass es keinen,
sage ich jetzt mal, jemanden gab, der die Peitsche und das Zuckerbrot in der Hand hatte.
Wir brauchen so eine Organisation, wo einer das Sagen hat und wir sind bereit, derjenige zu sein.
Wir haben ja auch schon mal was vorbereitet, Schublade aufgemacht und dann hatte
Frankreich tatsächlich ein Konzept, nicht in der Schublade, das hatten die natürlich
national im Kness schon einige Jahre oder einige Monate vorbereitet.
Jetzt muss ich gerade mal überlegen, ob ich die Reihenfolge der Buchstaben richtig bekomme.
Genau, das war LSE. Das war der Lanceur Substitution Europa.
Also der Ersatzträger von Europa, der Europa-Rakete.
Und aus diesem LSE wurde ganz schnell die Ariane.
Und der Ansatz war dann damals tatsächlich, CNES hat gesagt,
wir machen das jetzt. jetzt, wir sind bereit, es europäisch zu machen,
aber wir haben den Hut auf und wer mitmachen kann, kann mitmachen.
Das Gesamtmanagement wird bei uns sein, beim KNESS und wir sagen, wo es lang geht.
Und dann haben einige Länder, die bei dieser Europa-Raketengeschichte mit dabei
waren, gesagt, okay, wir lassen uns nochmal auf den Versuch drauf ankommen,
machen da mit, Deutschland unter anderem.
Die Briten haben gesagt, nee, unter den Franzosen nicht.
Natürlich war das nicht der Grund, aber nicht der offizielle Grund,
den sie auch vorgeschoben haben, aber natürlich war klar, UK macht das ganz
bestimmt nicht mit Frankreich mit Hulauf.
Und dann hat man tatsächlich 1972 mit dem Ariane-Programm begonnen,
was sozusagen aus diesen Trümmern des Europa-Raketen-Programms sozusagen entstanden ist.
Und das ist interessant zu sehen, weil 1972, das ist drei Jahre vor Gründung der ESA.
Die ESA Esan wurde 1975 gegründet und das Ariane-Programm begann schon 1972 unter Kness-Ägide.
Und als die Esa gegründet wurde, wurde sozusagen die Ariane,
die damals noch nicht eins hieß, weil es gab nur noch eine,
die Ariane sozusagen mit so als Hochzeitsmitgift bei der Gründung der Esa,
weil die Esa entstand aus der alten Eldo und der.
ESRO, das war die European Space Research Organization, wurde die sozusagen
neu gegründet, wurde das Ariane-Programm sozusagen so als Mitgift für die Gründung mitgegeben.
Allerdings unter der Prämisse des CNES, dass es zwar ein ESA-Programm sein darf
und kann, aber das Projektmanagement tatsächlich weiterhin vom CNES durchgeführt
wird. Und das blieb auch so bis 2003.
Also obwohl es immer ein ESA-Programm war und die ESA sozusagen das Geld der
Teilnehmerstaaten eingesammelt hat,
war die Programmkoordinierung und
die Programmsteuerung der Ariane 1 bis 5 tatsächlich immer in Kness-Hand.
Also CNES muss man sagen, Zentrum für Weltraumforschung in Frankreich,
also quasi so ein bisschen das Äquivalent des DLR, ein bisschen anders aufgestellt,
aber im Prinzip genau das, es gibt ja immer die nationalen Organisationen, genau. Ja.
Genau. Und das ist halt auch ein Grund, warum Frankreich immer noch viel stärker
ist in den Bereichen, als wir es zum Beispiel sind.
Und es war damals schon so, am Ende, also bei Ariane 1 war es noch stärker,
aber heutzutage ist es so, dass man immer sagen kann, Frankreich hat ungefähr
die Hälfte Entwicklungs-, Finanzierungs- und Produktionsanteil an Ariane und
Deutschland immer so um die 20 Prozent, so als Grobanheit.
Und wie gesagt, das Programm wurde 1972 beschlossen und der Erstflug fand 1979 statt, am 24.12.
Also relativ zügig.
Also diese Entwicklungszeiten kriegt man heute nicht mehr hin.
Und die kriegt auch ein Elon Musk mit SpaceX nicht hin. Das hat bei Falke 9 auch länger gedauert.
Also das ist schon so, dass man damals schon auch anders gearbeitet hat.
Anders inwiefern?
Das ist jetzt eine persönliche Meinung von mir, das ist jetzt keine irgendwie... Ich glaube...
Also es wurde damals auch schon sehr viele Dokumente geschrieben und es wurden
Trade-offs gemacht und es wurden Justification-Files geschrieben und sowas.
Aber ich glaube, dass damals, und das ist auch etwas,
wo ich der Meinung bin, was die ganzen Newspace und die Start-up-Firmen und
Organisationen auch zu nutzen wissen, man war damals noch mehr in den Kinderschuhen.
Und diese ultra-hierarchischen Systeme, ob das jetzt bei der NASA ist oder bei
Ariane Group, bei Airbus oder auch bei Lockheed oder bei Boeing,
die hatten doch gar nicht die Möglichkeit,
sich so zu verhärten.
Und das war auch noch eine Zeit, da hat dann glaube ich der Chefingenieur einfach
seinen Leuten geglaubt, wenn die gesagt haben, das funktioniert.
Dann mussten die nicht noch 200 Seiten Dokument schreiben, wo genau drinsteht,
ja es funktioniert wirklich.
Und dieses Vertrauen den eigenen Leuten gegenüber und auch irgendwie die kurzen
Wege und vielleicht Hierarchien, die nicht irgendwie x-Ebenen haben,
sondern vielleicht nur zwei oder drei, was wie gesagt die Startups auch machen,
das war damals auch dann in dieser Welt noch so.
Und ich glaube, das ist auch ein Element, wie man schneller und agiler sein kann.
Und wie gesagt, das ist damals, glaube ich, schon vergleichbar gelaufen wie
dann mit SpaceX oder bei den anderen Startups heute auch.
Also das ist jetzt nichts komplett Neues.
Klar, ich meine, wenn alles noch...
Unklar ist, wie man überhaupt geht, dann hat man natürlich auch in gewisser
Hinsicht die Freiheit, mal in jede Richtung zu forschen.
In dem Moment, wo sich irgendeine Technik etabliert hat, wo sich irgendeine
bürokratische oder wirtschaftliche Struktur gebildet hat, die dann auch betüttelt
werden möchte, dann wird es natürlich dann nicht mehr ganz so einfach.
Aber naja, geht ja trotzdem noch irgendwie weiter. Aber so begann dann das Ariane-Programm,
du hast es schon gesagt, 1979 startete dann die Ariane 1 das erste Mal.
Wie viel hat da funktioniert von dem, was man vorhatte?
Ziemlich viel. Also die Ariane 1,
die war Erstflug und erfolgreich und die wurde damals ja nicht entwickelt,
um irgendwie irgendeinen Markt zu bedienen, sondern die wurde entwickelt,
damit europäische institutionelle Nutzlasten gestartet werden können.
Forschungssatelliten, Metasatelliten und so weiter.
Und das kam aber genau in dem Zeitraum, wo dann das amerikanische Space Shuttle
nicht das liefern konnte, was es versprochen hatte.
Also ursprünglich war ja der Plan der Amerikaner, wir schaffen alle Raketen
ab und starten alles mit dem Space Shuttle und die Startkadenzen,
die immer geplant waren,
die konnten nicht erfüllt werden und deswegen gab es immer noch einen großen
Bedarf, über das Space Shuttle hinaus Startdienstleistungen anzubieten.
Und zeitgleich kam es dann auch, dass dann viel mehr Bedarf war zu starten,
auch gerade bei der sich dann auftuenden kommerziellen Telekommunikationsfirmen.
Und Ariane kam dann tatsächlich genau in so einem goldenen Moment als kommerzieller
Anbieter auf dem Markt. Und das ist auch wieder so ein Element.
Also ich sage immer, der erste Raketen-Startup war eigentlich Ariane.
Die tatsächlich die ersten richtigen waren, die dann auch auf dem kommerziellen
Markt, das ist auch so ein Element, also einen richtig kommerziellen Startdienstemarkt
gibt es eigentlich auch nur so semi.
Das ist jetzt nicht so, wie wenn man ein Auto kauft, das muss man auch ganz
ehrlich sagen und noch nicht mal so, wie man ein Flugzeug kauft.
Das ist schon nicht so wirklich ein Markt im Adam Smithischen Sinne.
Aber es gibt schon Angebot und Nachfrage.
Es gibt schon Angebot und Nachfrage, aber es ist nicht so, dass das in irgendeiner
Art und Weise so funktioniert.
Die Preisbildung funktioniert nicht so wie im klassischen wirtschaftlichen.
Aber okay, das noch am Rande. Aber Ariane kam zum richtigen Zeitpunkt und in
den 80ern und 90er Jahren wurden die Arianes 1 bis 4,
also 1 bis 4, zwischen 1 und Ariane 4 gibt es technisch keine großen Unterschiede,
da wurden immer bloß ein bisschen die Triebwerke verbessert und die Tanks größer
gemacht, deswegen subsumiere ich die jetzt mal einfach unter einem Ding,
die wurden verkauft wie warme Semmel.
Also die konnten gar nicht so viele herstellen, wie eigentlich Bedarf war.
Ich meine, zu dem Zeitpunkt war ja im Prinzip die Raumfahrt auch so ein bisschen
seiner initialen Explorationsphase und der ersten Begeisterung so ein bisschen entwachsen.
Also man hatte halt so, klar...
Erste Experimente, dann natürlich die Mondlandung als das große Ziel und danach
merkte man schon, da war dann aber auch so ein bisschen die Luft raus.
Die Amerikaner konnten sich dann für weitere Mondlandungen nicht mehr so richtig begeistern.
Man suchte sozusagen nach einer neuen Aufgabe, aber dann auch so im Rausch der
Möglichkeiten und des Science-Fiction-Wahns ist man dann eben quasi diesem Weg
der wiederverwendbaren Raumfahrzeuge gefolgt,
was ja an sich auch irgendwo funktioniert hat.
Und es gab ja auch zahlreiche Projekte, wo man sagen kann, okay,
da sieht man auch, dass das im Prinzip jetzt nicht so eine doofe Idee war.
Stichwort Hubble, man setzt es aus, dann funktioniert was nicht,
dann fliegt man nochmal hin, dann repariert man das.
Das sind ja alles so Sachen, die ohne das Space Shuttle jetzt auch gar nicht
so möglich gewesen wären. Nur war eben der Aufwand, um dann das zu maintainen, viel zu groß.
Also finanziell, technisch und dann mit der Challenger-Katastrophe etc.
Merkte man dann auch, okay, die Komplexität ist nicht mehr so beherrschbar.
Und diese Wiedergeburt sozusagen der klassischen Rakete, also im Sinne Wiedergeburt
innerhalb des Systems, welchen Wert die Rakete an sich darstellt.
Genau da kam dann im Prinzip Europa und hat gesagt, so eine Rakete haben wir
hier, haben wir jetzt mal lange genug drüber nachgedacht.
Gucke mal, scheint auch ganz gut zu funktionieren und passte auch von der Größe,
wenn ich das richtig sehe,
genau für diese neuen Anwendungen, weil man jetzt gemerkt hat,
okay, jetzt wollen wir nicht mehr die großen politischen Durchbrüche feiern,
sondern jetzt gibt es auch Nutzen.
Jetzt brauchen wir Satelliten, jetzt wollen wir uns irgendwie die Welt von oben anschauen.
Wissenschaft ist jetzt nicht nur so eine Vorstellung, sondern tatsächlich eine Primäranwendung.
Und da war im Prinzip das Ariane-Programm genau zum richtigen Zeitpunkt am Start.
Absolut, absolut. Absolut.
Wie ich gesagt habe, man kam genau zum richtigen Zeitpunkt da an, wo der Bedarf da war.
Das war jetzt nicht in irgendeiner Art und Weise von langer Hand geplant,
sondern das war tatsächlich Glück, muss man so sagen.
Und die Frage ist jetzt, ob dieses Glück im Nachhinein … Also dieses Glück hat
natürlich die Ausrichtung der Ariane-Welt auch relativ stark mehr oder weniger bestimmt.
Also ich hatte am Anfang gesagt, eigentlich wurde die Ariane entwickelt,
um institutionelle Nutzlasten zu starten.
Und das ist immer noch mehr oder weniger der Grund, warum wir eigentlich europäisch
Steuergeld ausgeben, um eine Rakete zu entwickeln.
Es geht darum, dass man nur souverän im Weltall agieren kann,
wenn man souverän in den Weltall kommt. Und dazu braucht man eine eigene Rakete.
Da will ich nochmal ganz kurz in das Jahr 72 zurück, als wir noch keine eigene Rakete hatten.
Ich weiß nicht, ein paar Zuhörer haben wahrscheinlich die Symphonie-Geschichte schon kennen.
Das war ein Telekommunikationssatellit, eine Kooperation aus Deutschland und
Frankreich, der 1972 hätte gestartet werden sollen.
Und das wäre mehr oder weniger so der Vorläufer des ersten drei Achsen stabilisierten
Telekommunikationssatelliten, wie man ihn heute kennt.
Früher gab es diese ganzen Tonnen immer.
Aber dieser drei Achsen stabilisierte Satellit, also mit den Solarzellen nicht
drumherum, sondern mit Flügeln, das war halt eine Neugeneration,
die auch eine viel höhere Leistung hatte.
Und das hatten die Europäer entwickelt und die wollten den auch starten,
hatten aber keine Rakete.
Und dann ist man zu denen gegangen, die Raketen haben, die Amerikaner und die
haben dann gesagt, ja starten wir euch gerne, aber ihr dürft den aber kommerziell nicht nutzen.
Obwohl da eigentlich für eine kommerzielle Nutzung geplant war.
Also 72, da sollte glaube ich irgendwie Olympische Spiele übertragen,
irgendwie sowas. und die Amerikaner haben gesagt, ja wir starten das Ding,
ihr dürft das aber nur als.
Telekommunikationsexperimentalsatelliten benutzen und damit kein Geld verdienen
und da hat man gesehen, okay, selbst unsere Freunde, die Amerikaner,
nutzen das aus, um sozusagen unliebsame Konkurrenz mehr oder weniger am Boden
zu lassen oder sie nicht wirtschaftlich zu machen.
Und deswegen war, das war ein Zeichen, dass es sinnvoll war,
mit einer Ariane angefangen zu haben und vorher mit einer Europa-Rakete angefangen
zu haben. Und das ist auch das Element, warum es ganz wichtig ist,
dass Europa eigene Raketen hat.
Es gibt immer Leute, die sagen, ja Gott, dann gehen wir halt zu Elon Musk und
dann kaufen wir uns einen Falcon 9.
Ja, ja, solange es noch andere Möglichkeiten gibt, ist das eine Methode,
die man machen kann, um Geld zu sparen vielleicht.
Aber sobald Europa keine Raketen mehr hat, also ich weiß nicht,
ob sich die Galileo-Kollegen oder die Erdbeobachtungskollegen vollkommen abhängig
machen wollen von den, sage ich jetzt mal, Befindlichkeiten von Elon Musk.
Und nicht nur von den Befindlichkeiten.
Auch die Kooperation mit den Russen, die ja hier lange Zeit intensiv verfolgt
wurde und die dazu führte, dass es eine eigene Startrampe gab in Kourou,
also auch immer noch gibt, aber jetzt nicht genutzt wird für die Soyuz-Raketen.
Haben wir jetzt gesehen, wie die politischen Konflikte rund um den Ukraine-Krieg
auch solchen Ambitionen schnell ein Ende setzen kann.
Ganz genau. Und da sieht man, also wenn man die Technologien nicht selbst hat
und darauf zugreifen kann, dann ist man im Endeffekt ausgeliefert.
Und deswegen ist es halt auch so wichtig, dass die Ariane 6 jetzt mal zügig
in die Pötte kommt. Aber da kommen wir, glaube ich, später noch drauf.
Genau.
Gehen wir nochmal auf das eigentliche Erfolgsprogramm, weil Ariane 1 bis 4,
das war im Prinzip so das, was eigentlich die europäische Raumfahrtindustrie
dann erst so richtig aus der Taufe gehoben hat,
weil darum geht es ja auch, es geht ja nicht nur darum,
dass man jetzt eine nationale Behörde hat, sondern es ging ja schon immer auch
darum und auch weiterhin eine entsprechende Industrie großzuziehen,
die natürlich nur dann existieren kann, wenn es auch einen fortwährenden Bedarf gibt.
Das ist ja auch so ein Aspekt bei diesen Bewertungen mit, oh Gott,
so viel Geld, was uns das alles kostet.
Ich glaube, wenn man da mal nachrechnet und sieht, okay, da die ganze Kohle
in Europa reingeht und es ja auch immer diesen Verteilungsschlüssel gibt,
dass wenn jetzt irgendein Projekt aufgesetzt wird,
dass dann eben das, was die Länder lokal investieren, also sagen wir mal jetzt
diese 20 Prozent, von denen du gesprochen hast, bei der Ariane,
die Deutschland dort reinsteckt, Diese 20 Prozent fließen ja dann auch wiederum
an deutsche Unternehmen,
das ist entsprechend geregelt, sodass man dann eben damit automatisch auch immer
eine lokale Industrie füttert, die dann diese Technologien entwickelt.
Know-how aufbaut, Leute ausbildet, Infrastruktur und Produktionskapazitäten
schafft, dass wenn eben der Bedarf besteht, dass man dann eben nicht erst so
dasteht und sagt, ach was wollt ihr haben, so eine Rakete, sowas haben wir ja noch nie gemacht.
Sondern dass das einfach da ist und dass man im Prinzip damit arbeiten kann.
Das ist natürlich immer so ein Balanceakt, weil auf der anderen Seite, okay,
jetzt haben wir vielleicht gerade mal nicht so viel Bedarf oder so viel Mittel,
wenn wir das jetzt aber zu sehr kürzen, dann führt es dazu,
dass dann eben die Leute die Industrie verlassen und wenn wir dann fünf Jahre
später wieder feststellen, oh, jetzt haben wir aber dann doch wieder Bedarf,
dann stehen wir halt doof da.
Das ist natürlich immer sehr schwierig zu machen.
Aber jetzt ging es ja erstmal ganz gut los.
Wann begann sozusagen die Erkenntnis, dass man mit diesem Ariane...
Mit diesem ersten Ariane-Modell, was dann halt Ariane 1 bis 4 war, nicht mehr vorankam.
Ja, das ist auch eine interessante Geschichte. Man hatte die Ariane 5 als Nachfolgemodell,
die war eigentlich originär gar nicht dafür gedacht gewesen,
diesen Bedarf zu bedienen oder dem zu dienen.
Die Ariane 4, die hat zu dem Zeitpunkt alles noch wunderbar geflogen und die
Ariane 5 war 1985, wurde ein Vorbereitungsprogramm beschlossen,
1987 das richtige Entwicklungsprogramm.
Das wurde gemeinsam beschlossen, jetzt sind wir wieder bei wiederverwendbaren
Raumfähren und Gleitern, zusammen mit dem Hermes-Projekt.
Also muss man sagen, das ist wieder so ein typisch deutsch-französisches Ding.
Zu den damaligen Zeiten, diese Aufteilung ist heutzutage nicht mehr ganz so
hundertprozentig, war Raketen stark von den Franzosen dominiert und bemannte
Raumfahrt war etwas, was den Deutschen sehr wichtig war.
Und da hat man dann sozusagen bei dieser Ministerratskonferenz,
also Ministerratskonferenzen, das sind Meetings, die alle zwei,
drei Jahre stattfinden, wo auf Minister-Ebene der ESA sozusagen große Programme aufgegeben werden,
das nochmal zur Erläuterung, dass auf der Ministerratskonferenz dann gesagt
wurde, wir vereinigen die deutschen und die französischen Interessen,
wir bauen eine neue Rakete, das wollte Frankreich sowieso, eine Ariane 5 mit
neuen Technologien, also hauptsächlich Wasserstoff, Sauerstoff.
Die Ariane 1 bis 4, die war.
Energetisch schlechteren Treibstoffen ausgestattet und die Deutschen,
die konnten dann dafür sozusagen den Hermes-Gleiter entwickeln hauptsächlich
und die Rakete ist darauf ausgelegt, diesen Hermes-Gleiter, also so eine Art Mini-Shuttle,
ins Weltall zu schießen.
Und das war mehr oder weniger der Startschuss für die Ariane 5,
die, wie gesagt, zu dem Zeitpunkt überhaupt noch gar nicht gedacht war,
um irgendwie Satelliten zu starten.
Im Laufe der Entwicklung war es dann so, wie es immer so ist.
Hermes wurde schwerer, die Leistungsfähigkeit der Ariane prognostiziert wurde
weniger, sodass am Ende des Tages rauskam oder sich ergeben hat,
Hermes war zu spät, war zu schwer, wurde auch zu teuer.
Und dass man sich dann entschlossen hat, Hermes einzustellen,
weil es war auch, glaube ich, technologisch, hat man sich sehr weit aus dem
Fenster gelehnt oder sich mehr zugetraut, als man dann eigentlich konnte.
Und das war dann Anfang der 90er Jahre.
Aber gleichzeitig hat man dann gesagt, okay, aber die Ariane 5 entwickeln wir trotzdem weiter.
Hätte man ja sagen können, okay, der eigentliche Nutzungszweck ist jetzt ja weggefallen.
Wir haben eine Ariane 4, die ist irgendwie für alle Bedarfe gut geeignet,
die wir haben, also gerade für unsere institutionellen Bedarfe.
Die Ariane 5 ist eigentlich dafür gar nicht optimiert.
Aber das ist ein Ja, also die Antwort wäre Ja gewesen.
Man hat sich aber trotzdem entschieden, die Ariane 5 weiterzuentwickeln und
sie dann statt Hermesse starten zu lassen, ganz normal Satelliten starten zu lassen.
Auch unter der Aussage, dass seit den 80er Jahren in die 90er Jahre hinein und
erkennbar auch in die Zukunft, die durchschnittlichen Satellitenmassen immer
weiter angestiegen sind.
Man hat dann auch festgestellt, das ist auch korrekt bei der Ariane 4,
Die hat wirtschaftlich davon profitiert, dass sie sehr oft oder meistens sogar
zwei Satelliten gleichzeitig starten konnte,
sodass sozusagen sich zwei Satelliten den Preis der Rakete teilen konnten,
sodass es für die nochmal günstiger wurde.
Aber es kam dann gegen Ende hin der Nutzungszeit der Ariane 4 immer öfter,
dass nur noch ein Satellit gestartet werden konnte, weil die durchschnittlichen
Satellitenmassen sich halt nach oben bewegt haben.
Sodass man gesagt hat, okay, wir haben jetzt eine Ariane 5, die ist darauf zwar
nicht optimiert, aber vielleicht ist das das Problem für die ansteigenden Satellitenmassen.
Wir entwickeln die jetzt mal so, dass die dann auch dieses Marktsegment bedienen kann.
Und das hat man dann auch gemacht und ist dann 1996 zum ersten Mal gestartet,
was leider allerdings ein Misserfolg war aus softwaretechnischen Gründen.
Das ist eine richtig, richtig interessante Geschichte.
Das wird jetzt hier zu weit führen, da die Details zu erklären.
Den Untersuchungsbericht kann man aber tatsächlich immer noch online finden.
Es wird immer gesagt, man hat Teile der Ariane 4 benutzt und die waren nicht
qualifiziert. Das ist alles ein bisschen vereinfacht dargestellt.
Aus dem Belageregelungssystem Sensorteile und Kreisel benutzt.
Man hat allerdings die Software nicht darauf angepasst, an die Variablengrößen,
sodass es zu einem Buffer-Override kam.
Also ganz vereinfacht gesagt, die Variablengrößen waren für die Flugparameter der Ariane 4 ausgelegt.
Und man hatte nicht bedacht, ganz vereinfacht gesagt, dass die Werte,
die dann kommen, vielleicht nicht in die Variablengrenzen hineinpassen,
bei einer Ariane 5 auftauchen.
Was dann dazu geführt hat, dass dann so eine Art Buffer-Overflow war und dann...
Okay, klassisches Software-Problem.
Ja, und das ist interessanterweise immer noch ein großartiges Lehrstück in IT,
Sicherheitsengineering. Das ist...
Das muss ja auch alles erstmal gelernt werden. Das sind so Dinge,
Ja, die merkt man dann halt auch erst, wenn sie schief gehen und das ist ja
bei der Raumfahrt auch so ein Klassiker.
Die Amerikaner hatten das ja auch bei ihren Marslandungen. Ich weiß gerade nicht,
welche Mission das war, die da schief gegangen ist, weil dann doch nochmal ein
bisschen mit imperialen Maßeinheiten gerechnet wurde.
Das kann halt ganz schnell in die Hose gehen und das bedeutet ja letzten Endes
nur, man braucht eben auch im Softwarebereich eine Art Management,
wie man sich dann sozusagen in der Hardware bereits angewöhnt hatte,
aber Software war so lange Zeit etwas verkannt, sodass man dann dachte,
naja, dann muss man das halt ein bisschen programmieren und sowas.
Was kann schon schief gehen und so stellt sich raus,
so ziemlich alles kann schief gehen und vor allem ist die Komplexität,
die Software so an den Tag legt, nochmal ein ganz anderes Engineering,
als man das jetzt vielleicht bei anderen Prozessen so kennt,
weil sich Dinge nicht so ohne weiteres messen und vorhersagen lassen.
Du hast vollkommen recht und das ist auch am Ende des Tages in allen größeren
Entwicklungsprogrammen, ob das jetzt Raketen sind oder Satelliten,
das, was mehr oder weniger immer die rote Laterne hat, ist Software.
Ist bei Ariane 6 auch so.
Jetzt momentan gerade nicht mehr, aber ein Großteil des Entwicklungsprogrammes
war Software und Avionik immer der kritische Pfad.
Gut, ich meine, hat natürlich auch damit zu tun, dass Software in gewisser Hinsicht
Dinge auch erst möglich macht, die man jetzt rein mit normalen klassischen Hardware-Regelungssystemen
nicht so erreichen könnte.
Also auf einmal ist man in der Lage, Grenzbereiche weiter zu nutzen,
ohne dass man noch mehr Technik reinstecken muss, wenn man sie halt nur halbwegs intelligent managt.
Aber das intelligente Management setzt natürlich dann eben auch entsprechend
voraus, dass man die Komplexität in dem Moment auch wirklich in den Griff kriegt.
Und das ist dann eben so eine Sache.
Aber Raumfahrt hat, sagen wir mal, auch der Softwarewelt, wenn wir auf dem Thema
kurz mal bleiben, auch eine Menge gegeben, weil ich denke, es gibt eigentlich keinen Bereich,
der gezeigt hat, wie sicher man Systeme auch machen kann,
wenn man so halbwegs vorausschauend an so Aspekte wie Redundanz und eine neue
Reprogrammierbarkeit schaut.
Ich meine Voyager 1 und 2, das allerbeste Beispiel wahrscheinlich,
Missionen, die jetzt irgendwie seit den 70er Jahren unterwegs sind und immer
noch fliegen und die immer noch, ich glaube wir hatten jetzt gerade im letzten Jahr, 23.
Gab es doch diesen Fall, dass auf einmal Voyager 1 oder 2, ich glaube auch 1,
kryptische Signale gesendet hat.
Auf einmal war das alles nur noch so ein Datenbrei und ich habe den Fall jetzt
nicht so genau verfolgt, aber ich glaube auch da ist man dann halt schnell wieder
einem Softwareproblem auf die Spur gekommen. War es so?
Ich denke ja, also ich kann mich auch nur oberflächlich daran erinnern,
aber ich finde es aber gerade auch, was die Voyager angeht, ich finde es halt
auch krass, das ist ja dann wirklich,
keine Ahnung wie viel RAM so ein Ding, wenn es Kilobyte sind,
ist viel so nach dem Motto.
Also da wird ja irgendwie jedes Bit so einzeln sozusagen in Betracht gezogen
und dass es da immer noch die Möglichkeit gibt, da auch noch an der Programmierung
was zu ändern und dann über diese Entfernung hinaus und dass es immer noch Leute
gibt, die das auch verstehen.
Also das geht da, also ich finde es immer lustig, wenn dann keine Ahnung,
irgendwelche Stellengesuche sind, weil irgendwelche Kobol-Programmierer gesucht
werden in irgendwelchen Finanz- und Bankengeschichten.
Also das ist, ja, also,
Also gerade in den Bereichen Raumfahrt und ist man glaube ich mit so ein paar
älteren Programmiersprachen, hat man glaube ich noch ganz gute Chancen.
Älteren Programmiersprachen oder ich glaube in der Raumfahrt,
also bei diesen ganz alten Systemen ist es ja sozusagen auch ein umfangreiches
Verständnis der gesamten Technik, weil die Hardware natürlich auch genau dafür gemacht ist.
Ich finde viele Aspekte davon sehr bemerkenswert, aber grundsätzlich,
dass die Systeme überhaupt in der Lage sind, sich auch immer wieder neu zu starten,
zuverlässig, dass sie immer wieder in der Lage sind, auf eine Version ihrer
Software zurückzugreifen, mit der sie sicher erstmal ein,
ich sehe die Erde wieder und ich bin in der Lage, weitere Kommandos entgegenzunehmen,
solche Zustände hinzubekommen.
Das ist super wichtig, jeder der schon mal Probleme mit dem Starten seines eigenen
Computers hatte und das sind wahrscheinlich so ziemlich alle,
also schnell ist man in so einer Situation, wo man sich durch Systemupdates
halt irgendwie alles verkackt hat und dann muss man eben neu installieren,
aber neu installieren geht halt nicht im Weltall und ja, also Software ist definitiv so ein Punkt.
Aber kommen wir nochmal zurück zur Ariane 5.
Also was war denn jetzt dann unterm Strich anders?
Nutzlast, Möglichkeiten, Volumen, alles ist ja ein bisschen aufgeproppt worden.
Kannst du mal so die wichtigsten Parameter vielleicht nennen,
die letzten Endes das neue Paket dann ausgemacht haben?
Also die Ariane 1 bis 4, die sind, also was wir sogenannte lagerfähige Treibstoffe
nennen, also das sind Treibstoffe, die bei Raumtemperatur flüssig sind.
Also bei Ariane 1 bis 4 sind das Hydrazinderivate und Stickstofftetroxid,
beides hochgiftige Sachen, also das ist auch das ähnliche, was die Russen in der Proton benutzen.
Vorteil ist, ist relativ also im Triebwerk einfach zu handeln,
weil sich das gegenseitig so selbst anzündet, man muss da nicht komplizierte
Technik schaffen, die kommen in Berührung und das macht Puff, aber es ist natürlich,
hochgiftig, hochkorrosiv und das Handling ist wirklich komplex,
also auch für die Leute, das ist glaube ich eine der gerade Hydrazin mit einer
der karzinogensten Substanzen, die man sich vorstellen kann kann.
Und das ist natürlich nicht so optimal.
Nicht nur im Handling, sondern auch im Schadensfall.
Richtig. Und das kommt aus der Historie tatsächlich dann auch der flüssig Interkontinentalraketen,
weil man diese Sachen, weil die flüssig sind, tankt man in die Rakete rein und
dann kann man das Wochen, Monate einfach betankt stehen lassen.
Wenn man dafür sorgt, dass dann die hochkorrosiven Sachen dann auch nicht die
Tanks kaputt korrodieren. Das sind aber alles lösbare Probleme.
Sie sind aber halt auch nicht so effektiv als Treibstoffe.
Also die effektivste Treibstoffkombination ist Flüssigwasserstoff,
Flüssigsauerstoff in der Verbrennung, die wir nutzen können.
Wenn ich effektiv sage, dann meine ich damit, was wir spezifischen Impuls nennen.
Möchte ich jetzt gar nicht erklären, was das genau ist, aber letzten Endes ist
es ein Wert dafür, mit wie viel Masse Treibstoff ich Vorschub erzeugen kann.
Also je höher der spezifische Impuls ist, desto mehr effizient kann ich den
Treibstoff, den ich mitnehme, nutzen.
Und Flüssigwasserstoff, Flüssigsauerstoff ist da halt in der Verbrennung mit das Optimum.
Man kann auch Fluor nehmen, das ist noch optimaler, aber das nimmt kein Mensch,
weil das ist noch giftiger.
Also deswegen ist das mehr oder weniger das.
Wasserstoff und Sauerstoff sind die hoch unproblematischen Stoffe. Ja.
Ganz genau. Also die sind nicht giftig, die muss man halt kühlen. Gibt es auch in Mengen.
Genau, kann man elektrolytisch herstellen, also wird auch in Kuh direkt hergestellt.
Muss man da nicht irgendwie mit dem Schiff hinschieben.
Und die Verbrennungsprodukte, die sind am Ende des Tages auch ungiftig,
weil es nämlich Wasser und Kohlenstoff, ja okay, okay, durch die Reaktion mit
der Luft entstehen auch noch Stickoxide.
Aber das ist alles vernachlässigbar gering, sage ich jetzt mal.
Also die Hauptreaktionsprodukte ist tatsächlich...
Schub und Wasser. Und das hat man halt in der Erststufe benutzt und benutzt
das auch in der Oberstufe, weil in der Oberstufe ist es eigentlich fast noch wichtiger,
so eine hochenergetische Kombination zu benutzen, weil es da weniger auf den
Schub ankommt, als auf diesen spezifischen Impuls.
Also jeden Kilogramm, den ich sozusagen in der Oberstufe sparen kann,
der kommt der Nutzlast zugute. Deswegen ist eine hohe Effizienz in der Oberstufe
für das Gesamtsystem noch besser als vielleicht vergleichsweise in der Unterschub.
Jetzt sag doch nochmal was zu diesem Unterschied zwischen Schub und Impuls.
Klingt ja jetzt erstmal wie, knallt raus, macht Wumms, beschleunigt. Wo ist der Unterschied?
Also Schub ist im Endeffekt, ich vergleiche jetzt mal ganz unwissenschaftlich
und unphysikalisch mit einem Auto.
Also der spezifische Impuls ist mehr oder weniger vergleichbar mit den Kilometer
pro Liter Tankfüllung oder wie viel 100 Kilometer kann ich pro,
wie viel Liter brauche ich da tanken.
Und der Schub ist im Endeffekt wie viel PS. Also der Schub ist die Kraft, mit der der Vorschub.
Das andere ist die Effizienz?
Das andere ist die Effizienz. Und
der Schub ist am Anfang wichtig in der Startphase, wenn die Rakete abhebt.
Und in der ersten Flugphase, weil dann die Erdgravitation noch auf die Rakete einwirkt.
Und natürlich muss der Schub, die Schubkraft muss am Anfang größer sein als
die Gewichtskraft der Rakete, weil sonst hebt sie nicht ab. Und das ist so ein
bisschen ein Nachteil von diesen Flüssigwasserstoff, Flüssigsauerstoff-Triebwerken.
Die Schubkraft ist vergleichsweise geringer.
Deswegen hat die Ariane 5 geringer als beim Hydrazin oder auch bei Kerosin-Sauerstoff-Triebwerken,
also das, was SpaceX benutzt.
Und also man kann auch ein Triebwerk bauen, was genügend Schub,
herstellt, flüssig Wasserstoff, flüssig Sauerstoff, das dann aber wieder dazu
führt, dass ich viel mehr Treibstoff brauche und das Volumen des,
also flüssig Wasserstoff ist halt vom Volumen her relativ viel,
also die Dichte ist halt gering, deswegen brauche ich dann wieder große Raketen
um groß, also groß genüge Tanks zu haben, um das da reinzukriegen und für Deswegen
hat die Ariane 5 halt auch 5,40 Meter Durchmesser,
weil man braucht ein ordentliches Volumen.
Und wenn man dieselbe Rakete mit demselben Schub mit Kerosin bauen würde,
wäre die Rakete vom Volumen her viel geringer.
Und um das auszugleichen, dafür hat die Ariane 5 die zwei Feststoffbooster,
weil Feststoff ist zwar in der Verbrennungseffizienz ganz schlecht im Vergleich,
aber es ist halt sehr einfach damit sehr hohen Schub zu generieren.
Man ist auch von der Technologie nicht so kompliziert, man braucht da keine
Steuerung und Regelungen und Pumpen, sondern das ist eigentlich wie so eine
Art große Silvesterrakete.
Machst du einmal an, dann macht es zisch und dann, wenn sie fertig ist, wird sie abgeworfen.
Und deswegen, das ist diese Kombination.
Also man hätte die Ariane 5 auch anders bauen können, aber das war halt das
Optimum damals für den Anwendungsfall, den man sich ausgeguckt hat.
Okay, also wer die Ariane 5 jetzt nicht so vor dem geistigen Auge hat,
das ist halt im Prinzip so eine lange Rakete, wo dann halt links und rechts
in der unteren Hälfte die zwei Feststoffbooster eben für den Start dran sind.
Das heißt, wenn das Ding startet, gehen die Feststoffbooster los,
aber die Hauptstufe zündet auch.
Also alles zündet sozusagen. Mit den Boostern wird dann eben gemeinsam mit der
Oberstufe diese initiale Überwindung der Gravitation durchgeführt,
bis man dann halt an so einen Punkt kommt.
Wie heißt nochmal dieser maximale Punkt?
Maximaler dynamischer Druck.
Wann wie viel es dann auch immer sind. Also bei der Ariane ist es dann halt im Prinzip die eine.
Und obendrauf hat man dann eben noch die eigentliche Nutzlast,
die ja wirklich verschwindend wenig Raumanteil hat an dem.
Aber die Raketen sind ja nochmal sehr groß, deswegen passt da oben auch noch was drauf.
Also nur mal um den Anteil zu sagen. Also bei der Ariane 5, die wiegt ungefähr 800 Tonnen.
Und die Nutzlast obendrauf, die wir in den GTO schießen, ist ungefähr 10 Tonnen.
Also man hat ungefähr so...
10 durch 800, also ein bisschen mehr als ein Prozent. Und der Rest wird weggeworfen.
Bei wiederverwendbaren Raketen wirft man weniger weg, aber letzten Endes ist
es halt einfach so, dass ein Großteil dieser Masse ist einfach der Treibstoff, der verbrannt wird.
Der einfach gebraucht wird, um diesen Vorschub und diesen Impuls sozusagen zu generieren.
So, die Ariane 5 hat hat also jetzt sozusagen diese Dimensionen nach oben gebracht.
Jetzt hast du schon eine Zahl gesagt, man hatte auf einmal eine deutlich höhere
Nutzlast, also man kann bis zu 10 Tonnen Also 10 Tonnen in den GTO.
Also man hat mal, also das ist auch interessant, also die erste Ariane 5,
da waren es ungefähr so 7 Tonnen.
Aber durch regelmäßige Weiterentwicklung, Verbesserung, auch durch eine neue
Version, die 2003 zum ersten Mal gestartet ist,
der Oberstufe, im Speziellen, also untenrum hat sich kaum was geändert,
hat man es dann geschafft, tatsächlich bei den letzten Flügen war die Nutzlastfähigkeit
in den geostationären Transferorbit, also das ist da, wo die ganzen,
Kommunikationssatelliten, also die Hauptnutzlasten der Ariane 5 hinfliegen,
auf bis zu fast 11 Tonnen zu steigern.
Also das ist wirklich, wenn man sich das überlegt, von 7 auf 11 Tonnen,
das ist schon mal eine ordentliche Steigerung.
Und Und vergleichsweise in den LEO, also den niedrigen Erdorbit,
kann die Ariane 5 so ungefähr 20, 21 Tonnen fliegen.
Also das ist auch schon eine ordentliche Portion. Also die ganzen ATVs,
also die automatischen Versorgungsraumschiffe, die von der ESA gebaut wurden
zur Versorgung der ISS, die wurden auch mit der Ariane 5 gestartet.
Und die nutzten dann auch die Nutzleistung komplett aus.
Also das war wirklich irgendwie bis...
Ein bisschen Marsch, aber da wirklich, also mit ATV war dann auch irgendwie
die 21 Tonnen tatsächlich relativ komplett ausgenutzt.
Und irgendwie, also das James Webb, da kann man jetzt, also die Nutzlast in
diesen Orbit, die ist nicht vergleichbar, weil das halt ein spezieller Spezialorbit
ist da an den Lagrange-Punkt, aber da ist auch die Performance tatsächlich auch bis auf den letzten,
Prozent ausgenutzt worden und das war halt auch wirklich,
ein sehr beeindruckender der Mission.
Also die Ariane 5 war insofern auch sehr universell einsetzbar.
Also sowohl für Low Earth Orbit, wo dann halt mehrere Satelliten in die Nutzlast
reingepackt werden konnten. Ich weiß nicht, was da so das Maximum ist.
Also Low Earth ist eigentlich, also ja, war möglich, aber die ist dafür aber
nicht hundertprozentig optimiert.
Also nicht optimiert ist das falsche Wort, aber die meisten Leo-Satelliten sind
einfach zu klein, um mit einer Ariane gestaltet zu werden.
Also bei den ATVs hat das Sinn gemacht, weil das eine große Nutzlast war.
Aber jetzt so, wenn jetzt irgendwie,
keine Ahnung, jetzt im Vergleich Starlink oder sowas mit Falcon,
diese Art von Konstellationen in Leo oder in Meo, in den mittleren Erdorbit,
diese Art von Nutzlasten, die gab es damals eigentlich noch gar nicht.
Die sind eigentlich erst jetzt so in den letzten paar Jahren groß geworden und
eigentlich würde Ariane 5 das wahrscheinlich auch gekonnt haben,
aber die Nachfrage nach Leo-Staats war tatsächlich eher gering.
Es gab hin und wieder mal welche, hauptsächlich im Erdbeobachtungssatelliten ziviler Art,
aber halt auch von Agenturen militärischer oder nachrichtendienstlicher Seite,
also die Erdbeobachtungssatelliten der französischen...
Geheimdienst, muss man so sagen, vom französischen Geheimdienst,
die wurden auch mit der Ariane 5 gestartet.
Aber das war nicht so die Hauptsumme. Die Hauptsumme an Satelliten,
die gestartet wurden, waren tatsächlich die GTO-Satelliten, die Kommunikationssatelliten,
die über viele, viele Jahre das Bread-and-Butter-Geschäft der Ariane-Spas waren.
Also wenn man jetzt guckt, Ariane 5 hat so sechs bis sieben Starts im Jahr gemacht
in ihrer besten Zeit und davon waren vielleicht zwei für institutionelle Kunden
und der Rest war kommerziell mit GTO-Sateliten.
Zum ATV, dem Automated Transfer Vehicle, habe ich ja auch bei Raumzeit mal ein
Gespräch geführt mit Nico Dettmann.
Das war auch sehr interessant, wo es dann auch wirklich genau darum ging,
wie kann man jetzt die Nutzlast mal so komplett ausnutzen. Raumzeit 17,
wer das nochmal hören möchte.
Auch schon eine Weile her. Das ATV-Projekt war damals noch im Betrieb.
Da fehlte glaube ich noch ein oder zwei von diesen insgesamt fünf Launches.
Das war ja auch sehr erfolgreich, weil es ja dann im Prinzip auch so der Vorläufer
war für das, was jetzt angestrebt wird bei der Artemis-Mission.
Da ist ja jetzt die europäische Raumfahrt mit der NASA zusammen auch bei den
neuen bemannten Raumfahrtprojekten dabei.
Okay, aber bleiben wir mal bei der Ariane 5.
Ariane 5 ist ja im Prinzip...
Das Erfolgsmodell eigentlich der europäischen Raumfahrt dann geworden,
weil man jetzt zum richtigen Zeitpunkt eine sehr zuverlässige Rakete hatte.
Okay, Softwareprobleme mussten erstmal ausgemerzt werden, aber nachdem der erste
Launch nicht geklappt hat, gab es danach, glaube ich, eine ziemlich unbefleckte Betriebsgeschichte.
Erstmal noch nicht, also der erste Start war 97, der zweite 98,
also der kam oben an, aber nicht genau da, wo man hin wollte.
Dann hat sie das so ein bisschen so mit ein, zwei Starts im Jahr so ein bisschen
so mühsam nach vorne getrieben und 2003 war dann der Erststart dieser neuen Version,
von der ich auch vorhin sprach, die auch eine Wasserstoffoberstufe hatte.
Also die erste Oberstufe der Ariane 5, die ging noch aus der Hermes-Zeit hervor.
Die hatte auch diese lagerfähigen Treibstoffe, also Hydrazin und Stickstofftetroxid als Kombination.
Und die richtige Nutzung der potenziellen Nutzlastfähigkeiten kam erst mit der
Version, die wir ECA nennen.
Das ist die Oberstufe, die auch Wasserstoff, Sauerstoff hat.
Und deren Erstflug war 2003 und der war halt auch ein Misserfolg.
Aber spätestens dann ging es dann eigentlich relativ schnell.
Also so ab Mitte der 2000er Jahre bis so in die 2000...
Ende der 2010er Jahre lief das dann tatsächlich sehr erfolgreich,
sechs bis sieben Missionen im Jahr und war ein Erfolgsmodell.
Also haben alle funktioniert. Also ich glaube, es gab insgesamt 117 Starts der Ariane.
Fünf davon sind eigentlich nur zwei so richtig in die Hose gegangen.
Das waren die beiden, die ich da...
Genau, und drei halt so, ja, hätte besser sein können, aber ging schon irgendwie.
Aber das ist ja eine super Quote. Also ich meine dafür, wie komplex das Ganze
ist und wie groß das Risiko ist, das
senkt ja dann letzten Endes auch die Gesamtkosten über die gesamte Zeit.
Weil man macht natürlich mit jedem erfolgreichen Start dann auch mal wieder
so einen Schritt nach vorne und wenn man dann nicht wieder alles in die Investigation
von Fehlern und Ausmerzungen derselben stecken muss, dann kommt man halt auch voran.
Was sind denn so die größten Erfolge der Ariane 5 gewesen?
Also ich würde sagen, weil es noch gar nicht so weit zurückliegt, James Webb.
Also das ist die teuerste zivile Nutzlast, die jemals gestartet wurde in einem Einzelstart.
Also wenn man jetzt vielleicht auch irgendwie ISS-Module mal außen vor nimmt.
Aber selbst dann, und das war großartig, dann….
Das war deshalb großartig, muss man sagen, weil es halt nicht nur geklappt hat,
sondern weil es so gut geklappt hat.
Dass die Lebenszeit des Teleskops um mehrere Jahre länger ist.
Also das Teleskop wurde so punktgenau auf den Zielpunkt abgegeben,
dass viel weniger Nachsteuerungstreibstoff gebraucht werden musste von James
Webb selbst, der jetzt benutzt werden kann, um länger die Mission zu betreiben.
Ich war beim Start nicht dabei, aber ich habe mitbekommen, was da im Vorfeld
auch alles gelaufen ist an Optimierungen.
Die NASA hat sich wirklich alles fünfmal angeguckt.
Wir, die ESA-Kollegen und auch die Ariane-Group-Kollegen,
Zwei, drei Jahre vorher, da war regelmäßig jemand von der NASA da und hat sich
da wirklich alles zeigen lassen und das war wirklich nur mal auf Herz und Nieren geprüft.
Also das war schon ein ganz spezieller Kunde.
Aber man hat gesehen, hat was gebracht und kam gut, also war super. Super.
Lass uns da mal kurz bleiben, weil ich glaube, das ist vielleicht dann auch
exemplarisch, auch wenn es jetzt so am Ende des Ganzen war oder vielleicht auch gerade deswegen,
weil man jetzt ja hier die gesamte Erfahrung dieses Projekts,
man kennt die Rakete, man hat eigentlich alle Fehler irgendwie schon ausgemerzt,
über 100 Starts, die zuverlässig funktioniert haben.
Es gab vor ein paar Jahren, gab es glaube ich nochmal so eine gescheiterte Injektion
oder so eine teilgescheiterte Injektion.
Da ist nochmal was schief gegangen, vielleicht genau zum richtigen Zeitpunkt,
was James Webb betrifft.
Aber man kann ja glaube ich gar nicht ausreichend beschreiben,
wie feucht die Hände der Raumfahrtwelt waren bei dieser Mission.
Also wenn jetzt irgendein Fernsehsatellit abregnet über dem Atlantik,
dann sagt man ja, scheiße gelaufen, aber es gibt halt ein bisschen weniger Fernsehen.
Bezahlt die Versicherung, baut man neu.
Genau, aber wenn jetzt bei James Webb irgendwas schiefgegangen wäre,
das wäre ja auch eine Schmach gewesen.
Das habe ich keinem gewünscht.
Bei Raumzeit 93 habe ich mich ja mit Günther Hasinger noch in Madrid vorher
noch über James Webb unterhalten und auch da war halt einfach klar,
also wenn das irgendwie schiefläuft, das wäre einfach eine Tragödie,
so würde man es mal sagen.
Dementsprechend aufgeladen war das.
Schreib doch mal, wie diese Vorbereitung auf diesen Launch so lief und wie wurde sichergestellt, dass,
Also wie hat man versucht sicherzustellen, dass man auch wirklich an alles gedacht hat?
Weil gerade so dumme Sachen wie die Software, ein falscher Wert,
der Buffer-Overflow etc., das musste ja auf jeden Fall verhindert werden. Wie macht man das?
Also ich kann da jetzt nur aus zweiter Hand berichten, weil das natürlich die
ESA-Kollegen gemacht haben, aber die Rakete, die für James Webb ausgesucht war oder selektiert wurde,
das war jetzt auch nicht, also keine Rakete, die hergestellt wird,
ist irgendwie eine vom Band.
Also das ist bei uns sicherlich ein bisschen was anderes als bei Elon Musk.
Wenn der da 50 Stück im Jahr startet, ist das glaube ich schon viel vom Band.
Bei uns ist es halt schon noch so, dass, also wir machen immer so ein bisschen
Witz, dass es irgendwie Manufaktur ist. Aber man muss schon sagen,
es ist vielleicht nicht unbedingt Manufaktur, aber es ist Prototypenbau,
würde man es vielleicht in der Automobilindustrie dazu sagen.
Und das ist auch etwas, wo wir bei Ariane 6 eigentlich weg von wollen,
dass man schon tatsächlich routinemäßigere Prozesse hat.
Aber bei Ariane 5 ist es schon wirklich noch so, also jede Ariane ist ein Einzelstück
und man hat dann halt auch als Firma und als ESA Möglichkeiten dafür zu sorgen,
dass die besten Teile selektiert werden.
Also das geht schon bei den Triebwerken los. Also jedes Triebwerk ist so in seiner Box eigen.
Also jedes Triebwerk wird ja, bevor es geflogen wird, wird es auch auf dem Teststand
laufen lassen. Also nicht nur bei der Entwicklung.
Jedes Triebwerk, was in die Rakete kommt, ist vorher auf dem Teststand gelaufen.
Und nicht nur einmal, ne?
Ja, also die Flugtriebwerke schon. Also die werden normalerweise nur einmal getestet.
Wird das dann hier in Lampolzhausen gemacht oder in Frankreich?
X-mal getestet.
X-mal getestet und also auch wirklich tatsächlich größenordnungsmäßig mehr,
als es eigentlich in einer Mission eigentlich zu erledigen hätte.
Aber jedes Triebwerk, was hergestellt wird, wird getestet und da kann man auch
schon sehen, ist es eher eins, was eher so an der unteren Grenze der Marge ist.
Also ist bei Automotoren wahrscheinlich genauso, weil irgendwie irgendwas nicht
so gut zusammenspielt, Toleranz und sowas.
Und man hat dann tatsächlich auch Teile, Triebwerke, aber nicht nur das,
ausgesucht für die Mission, die wirklich die besten sind, die man sich aussuchen konnte.
Und dann natürlich allein die Tatsache, dass die Qualitätssicherungs- und die
Projektleute der NASA, die waren in der Produktionsphase der Ariane 5,
die für Web genutzt wurde, immer mit dabei.
Also die waren in den Quality-Meetings, in den Projekt-Meetings und die haben
auch wirklich davor sich Dokumentation,
also man kann jetzt irgendwie salopp sagen, Ariane hat irgendwie die Hose runtergelassen
und hat sich dann tatsächlich untersuchen lassen, aber das war schon so.
Und das kann ich auch verstehen.
Also wenn ich irgendwie eine Nutzlast hätte, die, keine Ahnung,
was am Ende jetzt die Gesamtkosten waren, irgendwie 10 Milliarden oder sowas,
war glaube ich so die Größenordnung, wenn ich mich nicht täusche.
Da würde ich mir aber auch alles ganz genau angucken. Und das war halt auch
die Awareness in allen Bereichen der Kette, denen klar war, das Teil ist jetzt dafür.
Und ich glaube, dann überlegt man schon nochmal, mal, ob man vielleicht jetzt
da doch noch mal nachmisst.
Das ist genauso, stelle ich mir vor, also wenn man genau weiß,
dass es eine Rakete die bemannt fliegt, dann ist man glaube ich auch, also,
man pusht nicht bei einer nicht bemannten Rakete, das will ich nicht sagen,
aber ich glaube in der Awareness ist man trotzdem noch mal ein Tick,
aufmerksamer.
Also das war eine handverlesene Rakete sozusagen aus den besten Komponenten
geschmiedet, wo man sich absolut sicher sein wollte, dass einem hier nicht irgendein
Anfängerfehler unterläuft.
Also mit möglichst wenig Wavern. Also Wavern, das sind halt,
also früher waren es Zettel.
Also jede Rakete, die fliegt, hat irgendwelche Bauabweichungen. Es ist so.
Jedes Flugzeug, was fliegt, hat eine Bauabweichung. Also das ist ganz normal.
Nichts ist zu 100% konform.
Als gar nicht erst irgendwie in doch Risiken zu kommen.
Weil am Ende, eine Bauabweichung ist am Ende, auch wenn niemand unterschreibt,
trotzdem natürlich ein höheres Risiko als keine Bauabweichung.
Das muss man halt auch ganz, ganz offen und ehrlich sagen.
Und die multiplizieren sich ja in gewisser Hinsicht.
Und wie die dann zusammenspielen, das ist dann ja auch mal so eine Sache.
Und viele, sage ich jetzt mal, technische Probleme kommen ja meistens nicht
von einem singulären Ereignis, ist, sondern weil,
unvorhergesehene Beeinflussungen sich dann so gegenseitig beeinflussen,
dass es einfach nicht vorhersehbar ist oder nicht vorhersehbar war.
Das merkt man aber bei den großen Katastrophen. Ich weiß es nicht mehr ganz
genau, bei der Challenger-Katastrophe,
aber es ist nicht so, dass eine Sache nur gefehlt hat, sondern weil vorher noch
das gefehlt hat, dann hat das noch gefehlt und dann war hier die Toleranz nicht
ausreichend und dann ging die Katastrophe los und das macht ja solche Fails
auch so schwer vorhersagbar.
Das heißt, das war also sozusagen die gepflegteste, bestproduzierteste Ariane 5 ever, kann man sagen.
Ob ever, weiß ich nicht, aber zumindest in dem Zeitraum mit den Teilen,
die zur Verfügung standen auf alle Fälle.
Das Beste, was man liefern konnte, auf jeden Fall. Ja, das hat ja dann super funktioniert,
also hast du ja schon gesagt, die Trajektorie wurde dann so genau getroffen,
dass man also dem, ja der Mission,
ich weiß nicht, es gab glaube ich verschiedene Aussagen, aber irgendwas in der
Größenordnung von fünf bis zehn Jahre mehr Betriebszeit und das ist natürlich,
wenn die Betriebszeit an sich schon mal nur so in zehn Jahren,
so in Dekaden gemessen wird,
ist das natürlich eine, kann man sagen, fast eine Halbierung der Kosten und
das ist natürlich auch ein gutes Argument bei der nächsten Runde.
Ja, das war auf jeden Fall eine großartige Leistung und ja, ich glaube so in
dem Moment, als Arianes Bass gesagt hat so,
Wir haben das jetzt hier übergeben und wir haben es auf diese Art und Weise übergeben.
Das war dann, glaube ich, nicht nur ein Moment der Erleichterung,
sondern wahrscheinlich auch ein Moment des Stolzes, weil man sich hier eigentlich
im internationalen Raumfahrtgeschäft nochmal so richtig die Visitenkarte abgegeben hat. Da.
Bin ich mir ganz sicher, also definitiv. Und also ich meine,
das waren ja alle vorher angespannt, das ist ja auch logisch.
Und es waren in Europa die Leute angespannt. und wir haben ja auch so eine Veranstaltung
da gehabt und so. Und das war auch bei Ariane Group so.
Und ich meine, das ist am Ende noch mehr Leute werden auf dein Produkt zu so
einem Zeitpunkt, als zu so einem Zeitpunkt gar nicht gucken.
Also das ist jetzt am Ende des Tages, du landest so oder so in der Tagesschau.
Und an und für sich möchte man dann schon mit positiven,
Elementen in der Tagesschau landen und ich will gar nicht wissen,
wie das bei den Kollegen war, die dann in Kourou waren und ich will auch gar
nicht wissen, wie da also es gibt da eine Position, das ist der,
also was in Englisch Range Safety Officer ist, das ist sozusagen der,
der die Rakete sprengen muss,
wenn irgendwas unschön wird, also ich weiß gar nicht, wie die Kness-Kollegen,
ob die da gewürfelt haben oder oder auch bei den kürzeren...
Aber an dem Arm möchte man nicht der gewesen sein, der den Finger auf diesem
Knopf hat. Also da bin ich mir relativ sicher.
Aber irgendeiner hat es gemacht.
Beziehungsweise hat es nicht gemacht. Gab es denn außer dem Webstart noch etwas,
was man hervorheben kann aus der Ariane 5 Zeit, bevor wir mal auf die 6 zeigen?
Natürlich die ATV Starts, da haben wir ja schon drüber gesprochen.
Da Da hat auch alles wunderbar funktioniert.
Dann, was für die institutionellen Nutzungen ganz gut war, also zwölf der europäischen
Galileo-Navigationssatelliten wurden auch mit der Ariane 5 gestartet.
Und darüber hinaus Rosetta zum Beispiel.
Also ein Großteil der Sonden- und Forschungssatelliten, Satelliten,
die Europa in den letzten Jahren oder letzten Jahrzehnten gestartet hat, waren am Ende Ariane.
Herschel Planck zum Beispiel auch und.
Gerade die Deep Space Missionen, also die, die jetzt weit über den Erdorbit
hinausgehen, sind glaube ich auch das, was der europäischen Raumfahrt so den
Charakter verliehen hat in den letzten Jahrzehnten.
Das waren alles sehr erfolgreiche Missionen. Ich glaube, da gab es überhaupt
gar keinen nennenswerten Dropout.
Die sind alle top gestartet worden, top betrieben worden, haben alle unglaublich
gute Ergebnisse erzielt für die Wissenschaft.
Also das sind ja alles ganz maßgebliche Fortschritte auch für die gesamte Kosmologie
gewesen und sind es noch.
Und jetzt halt eben auch noch James Webb, auch wenn das natürlich eigentlich
ein NASA-Projekt war, aber eben dann unterstützt eben von der europäischen Raumfahrt.
Trotzdem kommt es ja jetzt zum Ende der Ariane 5.
Die letzte ist jetzt gestartet. Und jetzt soll es halt weitergehen mit der Ariane 6.
Seit wann geht das schon mit der Ariane 6?
Das ist ja alle Projekte deutlich später dann jetzt fertig geworden.
Wir sind ja noch gar nicht da. Also der Start ist jetzt, ich weiß nicht,
was ist der aktuelle Termin?
Einen genauen Tag gibt es nicht, aber Mitte Juni bis Mitte Juli ist das Fenster, was jetzt.
Also jetzt 2024 soll es dann endlich losgehen.
Seit wann wird an Ariane 6 gearbeitet und wie viele Vorstellungen,
was Ariane 6 denn letzten Endes mal sein könnte, gab es in dieser ganzen Zeit?
Also an der aktuellen Version, die jetzt entwickelt ist, die jetzt auch dieses
Jahr starten wird, wird gearbeitet seit Anfang 2015.
Also die Ariane 6, wie sie jetzt ausgelegt ist, wurde Ende 2014 beschlossen
auf der Ministerratskonferenz, also auf einer der Ministerratskonferenzen.
Und die Entwicklungsarbeiten begannen dann direkt 2015.
Es ging dieser Ariane 6 natürlich auch so ein bisschen Diskussionen im Vorfeld voraus.
Also es gab lange Zeit eine Diskussion, hauptsächlich zwischen Deutschland und Frankreich,
ob man jetzt schon eine Ariane 6 braucht oder ob man nicht eventuell mit einer
verbesserten Ariane 5 auch erstmal die Bedarfe abdecken.
Kann.
Das war damals die sogenannte Ariane 5 ME. ME stand für Midlife Evolution.
Das Entwicklungsprogramm hatte
2008 begonnen und man hätte dann eigentlich nur die Oberstufe ersetzt.
Und da haben wir angefangen, 2012 hat man dann beschlossen, man macht damit
weiter, bereitet aber parallel schon mal eine Ariane 6 vor.
Das war sozusagen so ein Kompromiss zwischen Deutschland und Frankreich,
sodass beide irgendwie sich darin sehen konnten Und 2014 war es dann so,
dass man gesagt hat, okay,
es sieht so aus, als ob das, was die Ariane 5 ME bieten kann,
also nicht das bringt, was man wirklich braucht, sondern es ist für alle Beteiligten
sinnvoller, direkt auf eine Ariane 6 zu gehen.
Und dann hat man sich 2014 zu dieser Ariane 6 entschlossen.
Dem gingen ganz viele politische Diskussionen voraus, kann man sich vorstellen,
weil die Ariane 5 weiterzuentwickeln wäre von den Kosten her natürlich weitaus
weniger kostenintensiv gewesen als die komplette neue Entwicklung an der Ariane 6.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz, man hat sich dann dafür entschieden und der Grund dafür
ist eigentlich relativ einfach.
Also man kann sich ja fragen, du hast ja schon gesagt, Ariane 5 irgendwie super
gute Erfolgsgeschichte, wir starten da irgendwie sechs, sieben Mal im Jahr,
haben Kunden ohne Ende, wir starten Champs Web und Pipapo.
Apropos, warum braucht man jetzt eigentlich Milliarden neu ausgeben,
um eine Ariane 6 zu entwickeln?
Und die Antwort ist eigentlich relativ einfach wie profan.
Am Ende des Tages ist es das Geld.
Weil eine Ariane 5 kostet halt mehr, als was der Kunde heutzutage bereit ist zu zahlen.
Jetzt kann man sagen, okay, es fliegen ja zwei kommerzielle Kunden mit,
aber selbst zwei kommerzielle Kunden, wenn man die Einnahmen zusammenrechnet,
sind nicht kostendeckend für die Ariane 5.
Deswegen hat man 2015 oder 2014 beschlossen, wir machen die Ariane 6 nicht als
neue technologische Meisterleistung, eine Rakete, die noch mehr kann,
weiter, höher, schneller,
sondern das Ziel der Ariane 6-Entwicklung war zum damaligen Zeitpunkt, eine Rakete zu haben,
die dasselbe kann wie eine Ariane 5,
aber modular ist, sodass sie auch den Teil übernehmen kann, den bisher die russische
Soyuz aus Kourou gestartet ist.
Aber gleichzeitig ungefähr, jetzt kann man sich streiten ob 40,
50 Prozent, aber ungefähr die Hälfte dessen kosten soll, was eine Ariane 5 kostet.
Das waren damals die Entwicklungsziele.
Und das war auch der Grund, warum man gesagt hat, okay, das ist es jetzt den
Staaten wert, diesen Schritt zu wagen, weil in den letzten Jahren der Ariane
5 war schon so, dass jeder Staat staatlich subventioniert war.
Also die erfolgreichen kommerziellen Starts mit der Ariane 5 waren am Endeffekt
nur deswegen verkaufbar, weil der Staat da Quersubventionen reingeschossen hat.
Und man wollte die Ariane 6 so entwickeln, dass der Staat diese Subventionen nicht mehr zahlen muss.
Und ist das gelungen?
Kurze Antwort, nein.
Weil?
Das ist kompliziert. Es ist immer kompliziert.
Im Vergleich zu Ariane 5, wurden bisher nicht erreicht. Das heißt...
Aus diversen Gründen, jetzt kann man sagen, okay, Inflation,
Energiekrise und kann man, ja,
es sind alles Elemente, die tatsächlich dazu beigetragen haben,
aber am Ende des Tages hat auch die Industrie vielleicht noch nicht das darstellen können,
was man erwartet hätte 2015 oder 2014. Also das ist ein Element.
Dann kommt hinzu, dass natürlich die damaligen Zielkosten definiert wurden auf
den Marktpreisen, die damals bestanden.
Wir waren damals natürlich schon so schlau und haben gesagt,
okay, das wird nicht so bleiben, das wird weiter runtergehen.
Aber der Abfall der Marktpreise im Vergleich zur Prognose war noch stärker,
als man es hätte annehmen können.
Jetzt guckt man sich an, Elon Musk fliegt halt 50 Mal im Jahr.
Also der hat 50 Raketen, wo er seine Fixkosten umlegen kann.
Wir haben irgendwie 10. Und das ist halt auch ein Problem, was alle Raketenbauern
letzten Endes betrifft.
Die Kostenbasis ist sehr stark Fixkosten dominiert und deswegen ist es eigentlich
gut, je öfter man fliegt, desto billiger wird der ganze Spaß. Spaß.
Auf der anderen Seite muss man aber auch aufpassen, dass man es nicht übergroß
baut, weil wenn ich dann die Kunden dann doch nicht habe und ich eine.
Überproportional große Infrastruktur habe und ich dann die Starts gar nicht
verkaufen kann, dann habe ich natürlich noch mehr Fixkosten und das ist so eine
Kombination aus vielen zusammenhängenden Geschichten.
Das ist, glaube ich, ohne eine Tafel immer sehr schwierig zu erklären. Aber letzten Endes ähm,
Die Preise sind weiter gesunken und die Kosten-Targets wurden nicht erreicht.
Das ist am Endeffekt der Grund, warum wir jetzt immer noch nicht in der Lage
sind, subventionslos eine Ariane 6 zu betreiben.
Wobei das ja jetzt nicht unbedingt ein Drama sein muss.
Wir haben ja schon gesagt, die Subventionen sind zwar erstmal da,
also man kann jetzt nicht nur durch den Verkauf des Staates alle Kosten wieder reinbekommen,
Nur das Geld, was ja in die Rakete gesteckt wird, ist ja Geld,
was man in die eigene Wirtschaft steckt und die ja dann irgendwie auf zweiter
und dritter Ebene auch Effekte hat mit Beschäftigung, mit Wissenschaft,
mit Knowledge und so weiter.
Das ist ja alles auch, glaube ich, unbestritten.
Nur hätte man trotzdem gerne eben weiter hier an der Schraube gedreht,
um eben diese absolute Marktfähigkeit oder Marktkonkurrenzfähigkeit zu erhalten. halten.
Was ist denn so der Hauptgrund dafür, dass diese Kosten so schwierig im Griff zu kriegen sind?
Was sind denn so Faktoren, die man vielleicht jetzt so auf den ersten Blick
nicht sieht, wo man sagt, warum kriegt ihr das nicht billiger hin?
Wenn ich darauf eine gute Antwort hätte, dann könnte ich damit,
glaube ich, gut Geld verdienen.
Ja.
Also es ist, also es wird oft, also ich sag mal so, Ich sag mal, woran es nicht liegt.
Es wird oft genug sowohl von der Konkurrenz als auch von Beteiligten im System
auch auf politischer Ebene oft genug gesagt, das liegt daran,
dass wir unseren Geo-Return und unsere europäische Verteilung haben.
Also Geo-Return ist das, was du am Anfang angesprochen hast,
dass ein Euro aus Deutschland in die deutsche Industrie fließen muss.
Und dass durch die gesamte Verteilung in Europa wir so hohe Kosten haben,
weil das von A nach B verstifft werden muss und sowas, das ist eigentlich Quatsch.
Also es ist nicht der Auslöser, dass unsere Kostenbasis so hoch ist, wie sie ist.
In den USA findet ja auch nicht alles an einem Ort statt.
Richtig. Und wenn man sich jetzt irgendwie die Automobilindustrie anguckt,
da wird ja auch das Auto nicht, also es kommt nicht alle Teile aus Wolfsburg,
sondern der Motor kommt, keine Ahnung, aus Tschechien.
Diese Art von Logistik ist ein Grundprinzip der westlichen Wertschöpfung.
Also das ist ganz normal.
Also wenn das nicht so wäre, wären die Autobahnen auch nicht so voll.
Und deswegen, daran liegt das nicht.
Und da war ja im Prinzip die Raumfahrt vorneweg. Also am Anfang klang das noch
komisch mit, ihr fliegt jetzt hier irgendwie eure Triebwerke dann nach Frankreich,
damit sie da wieder zusammengebaut werden können.
Nur wie du schon sagst, das ist ja eigentlich in der ganzen On-Demand-Logistik
vollkommen normal mittlerweile.
Wenn man Kosten senken will, dann gibt es ja eigentlich immer so diesen schnellen
Ansatz mit, naja, dann muss halt irgendwo weniger Sorgfalt erfolgen.
Und ich glaube, das ist immer so eine Abwägung.
Wie viel Geld muss ich jetzt investieren, um eine bestimmte Qualität zu erreichen?
Reichen und schnell kann man ja sagen so, ach, das wird schon irgendwie passen.
Dann brauchen wir uns ja nur ein anderes Beispiel in Deutschland anzuschauen
mit der Bahn, wo das ja nun lange Zeit,
vernachlässigt wurde, wo man gesagt hat, ja, so viele Reparaturwerke brauchen
wir nicht und die Schienen müssen wir jetzt auch nicht irgendwie regelmäßig checken.
Irgendwann fällt einem das halt dann auch auf die Füße und in gewisser Hinsicht
ist das ja auch ganz gut, dass man sagt so, ja, wir wollen jetzt aber auch in
bestimmten Bereichen keine Kompromisse machen, weil letzten Endes definiert
ja der Qualitätsanspruch die Kosten. Im Wesentlichen.
Das auf alle Fälle. Aber natürlich gibt es da auch so einen goldenen Balancepunkt,
wo man jetzt schon darüber diskutieren kann, ob der bei uns vielleicht nicht ganz getroffen ist.
Also ich bin schon davon überzeugt, dass es gewisse Prozesse bei uns gibt,
die nicht unbedingt nötig sind.
Die werden aber alleine nicht dazu führen, dass irgendwie, also das macht jetzt
nicht irgendwie 20 Prozent Kostenreduktion aus, da bin ich mir ganz sicher.
Es ist auch nicht so, dass die Technologie irgendwie diese Kosten produziert.
Das ist, glaube ich, ein Zusammenspiel aus vielen verschiedenen Elementen,
die einzeln für sich vielleicht beherrschbar sind, aber in dieser Gesamtmenge.
Also auch in der Art und Weise der große Dampfer, sag ich jetzt mal,
den zu optimieren und dann auch ein paar gerade, also es gibt schon seit einigen
Jahren und wir haben ein Kostenoptimierungsprogramm schon aufgelegt,
bevor die Ariane 6 zum ersten Mal geflogen ist.
Und das ist auch etwas, wo wir als Agenturen und Geldgeber natürlich auch ein
Interesse daran haben und das ist auch etwas, wo wo die industriellen Partner
auch ein Interesse daran haben sollten.
Und es gibt da auch Studien, die gewisse Wege aufzeigen, die...
Aber es ist auch wieder so ein Element, um diese Kostenreduktion zu gewinnen,
muss man natürlich auch erstmal wieder Geld investieren.
Und das ist dann so eine Frage der Bereitschaft.
Der Berechtigkeit der Politik etc.
Und die grundlegende Frage ist natürlich auch, da kommen wir jetzt wieder ganz,
ganz, ganz an den Anfang zurück eigentlich,
wofür entwickeln wir mit Steuergeld Raketen? um drei Satelliten weniger zu starten
als Elon Musk oder um unsere Satelliten, die wir selber starten wollen, zu starten.
Und das ist auch eine Frage, also aus reiner Souveränitätssicht müssen die Kosten
eigentlich erstmal nachgeordnet sein.
Du hattest ja auch gesagt, es ist ja kein Geld, das weg ist.
Also staatliche Budgets funktionieren ja nicht so. Also es wird immer so die
schwäbische Hausfrau sozusagen vorgehalten, aber so funktioniert ja nicht ein Budget.
Und du hattest ja auch gesagt, das landet alles wieder und es gibt da auch diverse
Studien und die aktuellste, die wir haben, die sagt, dass jeder Euro,
den du in den Raumtransport steckst, also raketenspezifisch,
hat einen Multiplikatoreffekt von 3,5.
Also für den gesamtwirtschaftlichen Mehrwert, das ist ja schon mal nicht gerade wenig.
Und nichtsdestotrotz ist es etwas, was schwierig ist.
Im Gesamtsystem die Kostenbasis so signifikant zu reduzieren,
dass es wirklich spürbar ist.
Und da gibt es diverseste Schlüsse, die man daraus jetzt ziehen kann.
Und ein Schluss ist, dass das System, das wir jetzt haben, so wie es aufgestellt
ist, also das Gesamtsystem aus ESA, aus Prime,
aus den nationalen Agenturen, so wie es zusammenarbeitet, vielleicht jetzt nicht
mehr unbedingt das Zukunftsmodell ist.
Es hat uns jetzt seit den 70er Jahren erfolgreich sozusagen die Fähigkeit gebracht.
Aber dass man überlegen muss, ob man im Ansatz da nicht anders rangehen kann.
Und das heißt nicht, dass wir die ESA abschaffen oder dass wir irgendwie die
Industrie abschaffen oder Agenturen abschaffen, sondern dass wir die Art und
Weisen, wie solche Entwicklungen in Zukunft durchgeführt werden, anders aufziehen.
So eine Art Space Airbus, also so eine Art Firma, die alles zusammenzieht und
das weniger auf die Länder verteilt, so wie das bisher war?
Ja, der Gedanke, der jetzt mehr oder weniger mehr vorherrscht,
ist eher, es so ein bisschen zu machen, wie die Amerikaner es mit SpaceX gemacht
haben, dass man gar nicht mehr Raketen im Auftrag entwickeln lässt,
sondern dass man sagt, okay,
wir kaufen Startdienstleistungen von euch ein und wir bezahlen nicht die Entwicklung
eurer Rakete, sondern wir stellen euch in Aussicht, wenn ihr eine Rakete habt,
Dann werden wir sie mit, keine Ahnung, fünfmal im Jahr benutzen und auf der
Basis könnt ihr irgendwie eine Kalkulation machen, ob es sich lohnt,
eine Rakete zu entwickeln.
Das ist ja eigentlich so das klassische Argument, was in dieser ganzen Debatte,
glaube ich, um SpaceX herum aufgebracht wird. Und das ist ja auch so.
Also die NASA hat eben diese Garantien und stellt einfach sicher,
dass diese privaten Auftragnehmer, es gibt ja nicht nur SpaceX,
sondern auch ein paar andere im Boot, die jetzt nicht ganz so performt haben wie SpaceX.
Das ist halt der Grund, warum SpaceX jetzt auch alles so überlagert und so dominiert.
Und dann letzten Endes auch diese Freiheiten geschaffen haben,
indem dann dieser Mut auch zu dem technologischen Fortschritt,
den SpaceX ja nun definitiv an den Tag gelegt hat mit der Reusability,
das dann eben auch umsetzen zu können. Also okay, ich sehe schon.
Also man versucht so ein bisschen zu lesen, was geschrieben ist und könnte also
dazu führen, dass sich hier strukturell in den nächsten Jahren,
Jahrzehnten auch nochmal Änderungen abzeichnen.
Auf alle Fälle. Und also eher in den Jahren als Jahrzehnten.
Und das heißt ja nicht, also das, was jetzt momentan so im Raum steht,
wenn man das verfolgt, ist das, was wir European Launcher Challenge nennen.
Den Namen finde ich ein bisschen, der ist so ein bisschen irgendwie,
der trifft nicht ganz das, was damit eigentlich gemacht werden soll, nämlich genau das.
Also es ist so ein bisschen wie das ehemalige Kotzprogramm der Amerikaner,
wo man tatsächlich, also manche...
Was für ein Programm?
Kotz.
Kotz?
Also C-O-T-S. Ah. Und ja, stimmt.
Steht für was?
Commercial Orbital Transportation Services, sowas in der Art.
Und das ist genau das, man stellt...
In Aussicht, Startdienstleistungen zu kaufen.
Und natürlich muss man dazu sagen, dass in Europa auf viel, viel,
viel kleineren Füßen aufgebaut sein wird als in den USA.
Wenn man sich die Budgets anguckt, also allein wenn NASA und das Verteidigungsministerium
da Startdienstleistungen in Aussicht stellen, da fließen Milliarden ohne Ende.
In Europa, selbst wenn man die EU-Kommission und die ESA zusammennimmt und die
Nationalstaaten, da ist das immer noch eine überschaubare Anzahl an Starts,
die man wirklich in Aussicht stellen kann.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz ist das etwas, wo man hofft, dass dann halt durch mehr
Player auch so ein bisschen die systemische, ich will nicht sagen Langsamkeit,
aber so diese eingefahrenen Polsituationen sich so ein bisschen irgendwie dynamischer bewegen.
Und es ist ja auch so, dass also Ariane Group oder Avio, die die Vega machen,
sind ja auch aufgerufen, sich dann daran zu beteiligen.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass es dann irgendwie ein Spiel, ein Sandkasten gibt für
die einen und irgendwie die Alten, Anführungsstrichen, die müssen dann daneben
warten, sondern das ist ja etwas, was.
Also idealerweise dem gesamten System eine neue Dynamik geben soll.
Und das ist halt die Hoffnung. Und.
Und das ist etwas, was tatsächlich aus der nächsten Ministerratskonferenz,
die soll 2025 sein, in Deutschland interessanterweise, der genaue Ort ist noch
nicht bekannt, tatsächlich beschlossen werden soll.
Jetzt müssen wir natürlich schon nochmal den Elefanten in den Raum lassen und
so technische Aspekte ansprechen, wie zum Beispiel diese Reusability.
Ganz klar glaube ich so, dass, also abgesehen davon, von, dass es irgendwie
vielleicht wirklich für die Kosten einen erheblichen Faktor darstellt,
weil man es nicht nur immer wieder verwenden kann, sondern einfach, ja,
Nicht der einzige Faktor bei SpaceX, aber einer der sichtbarsten Faktoren und
auch rein vom Marketing her natürlich grandios.
Ich glaube, da ist allen so ein bisschen der Mund runtergeklappt,
als man das erste Mal gesehen hat, wie die Dinger wieder landen können.
Richtig weggehauen war ich, als dann die dicke Rakete, die Heavy,
Falcon Heavy, als die dann gestartet ist und dann zwei Booster auch noch so
parallel, das war schon echt so ein Freeze- Moment.
Ist das sozusagen etwas, was bei diesem Ariane 6 Programm doch irgendwann kommen
wird oder ist das dann schon mal Ariane 7 oder Oder ein ganz neues Projekt,
wo so etwas angegangen wird?
Also bei Ariane 6 würde ich eine vorsichtige Skepsis sagen.
Also das ist ja, ich muss da ein bisschen ausholen.
Also es ist ja nicht so, dass die Europäer keine Reusability bisher machen oder
gemacht haben, weil wir es doof finden.
Also es gibt ja genügend durchgeführte Forschungs- und auch Testaktivitäten.
Also Themis zum Beispiel ist ja etwas, was auch die ESA macht,
was hauptsächlich von Frankreich getrieben ist.
Es gibt auch eine Kooperation Frankreich-Deutschland-Frankreich, was Callisto heißt.
Also nicht das Problem, sondern der Faktor ist ja eher Reusability,
sowohl industriepolitisch als auch finanziell rentiert sich erst ab einer bestimmten Jahreskadenz.
Und die ist abhängig von vielen, vielen, vielen Randbedingungen.
In Europa sagt man, es würde sich rentieren, wenn man vielleicht so 20,
30 Mal im Jahr fliegt. Weiß ich nicht, vielleicht auch bei weniger.
Aber die Kadenz, die Raketenkadenz, die wir jetzt haben mit sechs,
sieben Mal, ist etwas, da lohnt sich Reusability de facto nicht.
Nicht, weil man guckt sich jetzt an, irgendwie beim letzten Falke-9-Start,
das war, glaube ich, das 19.
Mal, dass einer von der Erststufe geflogen ist. Jetzt überlegt man sich,
okay, Europa hat irgendwie sechs, sieben Mal im Jahr eine Rakete am Fliegen.
Ich habe eine Erststufe, die kann ich 19 Mal nutzen, sag mal 21,
weil dann kann ich besser teilen.
Also ich habe drei Jahre lang keine Produktion.
Und ich habe aber trotzdem die
Produktionsinfrastruktur, Weil irgendwann muss ich ja wieder was bauen.
Und ich hatte ja auch einmal zwischendurch gesagt, dass unser momentanes System
sehr infrastruktur- und fixkostenintensiv ist.
Und deswegen ist in dieser Art von Denke Reusability macht so keinen Sinn eigentlich.
Das heißt nicht, dass wir es nicht können.
Und jetzt komme ich auf deine Ariane 6 Frage zurück, wo es auf einmal Sinn machen
würde, wäre zum Beispiel die Ariane 6, die hat ja vier Feststoffbooster, also die große Ariane 6.
Diese könnte man eigentlich sehr gut durch Flüssigbooster ersetzen und wenn
ich jeden dieser Flüssigbooster wiederverwenden würde, dann hätte ich auf einmal auch eine Kadenz von 40,
wenn ich zehnmal im Jahr fliege und dann auf einmal würde es schon irgendwie
wieder in der Kadenz der Produktion und der Wiederverwendbarkeit auch von den Zahlen her Sinn machen.
Und das ist auch etwas, das haben wir jetzt untersucht und da gibt es inzwischen
auch Aktivitäten, ob das bei einer Ariane
6 nicht in der mittelfristigen Weiterentwicklung sinnvoll sein könnte.
Bei der Erststufe würde ich ganz vorsichtig sagen, nee, weil da endet man die
ganze Rakete, dann hätte man direkt eine Ariane 7, definitiv.
Aber ich gehe davon aus, dass in der nächsten Generation europäischer Träger
das eine Rolle spielen wird.
Dann auch wieder, also die Reusability, die ist ja kein Selbstzweck.
Also, dass wir es können, bin ich mir ganz sicher.
Aber wenn wir jetzt an diese Launcher-Challenge rangehen und an diese vielleicht
Umorientierung wieder, wie das System in Europa funktioniert,
ist es dann in Zukunft ohnehin jedem,
der sich an der Dienstleistungsbereitstellung beteiligen möchte,
selbst überlassen zu überlegen, wie seine Rakete aussieht.
Und wenn jetzt Firma X sagt, okay, ich biete meine Rakete Reusability an, dann bitteschön.
Wir wollen da jetzt als staatliche Seite gar nicht technologische Wege vorgehen.
Wir sind da eigentlich vollkommen neutral, was die technologische Lösung angeht.
Bei Ariane können wir es noch nicht sein, weil die halt noch zu stark staatlich beeinflusst ist.
Also das ist für Ariane-Gruppen momentan natürlich auch nicht ganz einfach,
in so einer Phase quasi jetzt, der Herr Scholz sagt, das ist eine Staatsrakete, ist es de facto auch.
Und gleichzeitig versucht man parallel neben der Staatsrakete einen Biotop zu
schaffen, was die New Space Player irgendwie stärker mit einbezieht.
Also das ist momentan eigentlich strategisch eine unserer Hauptaufgaben,
um in diesem Spagat irgendwie einen Weg zu finden.
Der eine sinnvolle Zukunft gestaltet, ohne jetzt irgendwie schon Kinder mit
dem Badwasser auszuschütten oder sich Äste abzusägen, auf denen man sitzt.
Also das ist gar nicht so einfach in der aktuellen Situation.
Kann ich mir vorstellen. Aber man hat auf jeden Fall von der Technik schon mal
gehört und es ist sozusagen nichts wirklich Neues.
Nein, also wir gehen da nicht mit verschlossenen Augen hin und so, da brauchen wir nicht.
So, aber schauen wir nochmal jetzt vielleicht auf die Ariane 6 selber.
Was erwartet uns denn jetzt in diesem Jahr als Launcher-Paket,
was da in Kuro hingestellt wird?
Ich war ja selber vor Ort, schon ein paar Jährchen her,
konnte leider den Start selber nicht sehen, zu dem ich eigentlich eingeladen
wurde, da gab es viel Pech, aber ich habe den Platz gesehen,
als er noch in der Entwicklung war, da musste noch sehr viel Beton vergossen werden.
Ist schon irre, mal da gewesen zu sein. Man macht sich keine Vorstellung davon, wie groß das alles ist.
Also ein fettes Loch, was da gebuddelt werden muss, um einfach diesen Strahl,
der dann nach unten in den Boden geschickt wird, seitlich abzulenken.
Das alles muss irgendwie beregnet werden.
Riesige Flächen allein, um das Ding anzuliefern, zwischenzulagern etc.
Wird sicherlich auch vor Ort gewesen sein, nehme ich mal an, bei dem Startplatz.
Also das ist ja ohnehin erstmal das, was als erstes da sein muss.
Das macht man sich ja immer nicht so richtig klar.
Ich denke immer so, ja, Rakete, klar, stellt man irgendwo hin,
fliegt die dann halt los, kennt man ja so aus mit Science-Fiction.
Ist ja mitnichten so, sondern eine Rakete ist ja ein System.
Ein System, was nicht nur aus der Rakete selbst besteht, sondern aus den ganzen
Zulieferkomponenten der gesamten Logistik.
Wann wird welcher Teil woher gestellt, zusammengefügt, über den Teich geschickt?
Was wird vor Ort produziert? Wir hatten das mit den Treibstoffen.
Aber wie muss dann die Rakete gelagert werden?
Aber wie wird sie dann eben auch gestartet und kontrolliert?
Kontrollzentrum etc. Da hängt ja eine ganze Menge mit dran. Was ist das Gesamtpaket,
was uns mit der Ariane 6 jetzt erwartet?
Also das Gesamtpaket, also wir gehen jetzt davon aus, dass wir im Sommer,
also im Juni, Juli spätestens tatsächlich den Erstflug sehen werden.
Bis der stattfinden wird, wird es höchstwahrscheinlich, das ist momentan noch
in der Prüfung, in La Bolshausen nochmal einen Test geben für die Oberstufe.
Aber da wird gerade geprüft, ob man den nicht weglassen kann,
weil die Elemente, die man für den Erststart,
braucht, sind eigentlich schon alle durchgetestet deswegen,
checkt man da gerade, ob man nicht eventuell bestimmte Tests zusammenlegen kann mit einem Test,
das sowieso Ende des Jahres geplant ist, das war wie gesagt gerade in der Überprüfung
ansonsten die Stufen, die werden im Februar Europa verlassen.
Also die Stufen und Produktionsteile, die die erste Ariane 6,
die flugfähig ist, ausmachen werden, die werden im Februar Europa verlassen auf dem Schiff.
Das hat man bestimmt auch schon mal gesehen, das ist das mit diesen modernen Segeln.
Moderne Segeln? Ja, das ist auch ein kompletter Neubau. Das hat so.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ich bin kein Schiffbauingenieur, Aber das hat einen Motor,
aber das kann auch mit Segelunterstützung fahren.
Aber das sind halt nicht so Segel aus Stoff, sondern das ist so mit diesen rotierenden
Röhren, will ich jetzt mal sagen.
Aber muss man auf der Ariane-Space oder Ariane-Group-Seite mal gucken,
da gibt es auch Bilder, da sind sie auch ganz stolz drum. Das ist auch wirklich ein geiles Ding.
Und dann geht das dann dahin, wird entmontiert und dann hoffen wir,
dass da irgendwie im Mai, Juni da was auf dem Pad stehen wird.
Kanopé heißt das Schiffchen. Genau. Ah ja, okay. Verstehe, das sind diese,
ja wie nennt man die denn? Ja.
Also als Ingenieur, ich weiß, wie der Effekt funktioniert, aber wie das jetzt
genau heißt, weiß ich jetzt auch nicht.
Okay, aber es nutzt sozusagen die Windkraft mit aus und sowas gehört dazu, verstehe ich.
Ja und dann, wie gesagt, die Nutzlasten vom Erstflug, das sind halt alles so
kleinere Satelliten, da ist
jetzt nichts Großes dabei, sondern die bezahlen auch nichts oder wenig.
Das sind halt so CubeSats von Universitäten und Experimentalsatelliten von Instituten und sowas.
Und ja und dann hoffen wir mal, dass das alles gut funktioniert da im Juni und
wenn dann soweit alles ganz gut gelaufen ist, dann gehen wir davon aus,
dass wir in diesem Jahr noch mindestens einen weiteren Start haben werden.
Okay, aber vergleich mal die Ariane 5 und Ariane 6, was hat sich jetzt geändert?
Also von der Größenordnung nicht wirklich viel. Also die Ariane 6 ist ein bisschen
länger, aber der Durchmesser und die grundlegende Struktur ist genau noch dieselbe.
Also man hat eine Hauptstufe mit Flüssigwasserstoff, Flüssigsauerstoff.
Die wird auch de facto vom selben Triebwerk angetrieben, also vom Vulkan 2.
Bei der Ariane 6 ist es Vulkan 2.1, weil es bestimmte Unterschiede gibt.
Aber die sind nicht marginal, aber die sind überschaubar. Das sieht man dann
auch schon an der Versionsbezeichnung, sage ich jetzt mal.
Und die Oberstufe, die ist auch flüssig Sauerstoff, flüssig Wasserstoff.
Da unterscheidet sich schon eine Menge, weil die Oberstufe der Ariane 5,
die es gab, die war mit einem Triebwerk versehen, was nicht wiederzündbar war.
Aber das Triebwerk, was die Ariane 6 jetzt hat, das ist ein wiederzündbares Triebwerk.
Das heißt, dadurch bin ich in der Lage, viel optimiertere Bahnen zu fliegen,
weil ich kann ballistische Phasen ausnutzen und ich kann das Triebwerk wiederzünden,
wenn es energetisch im Orbit an einer viel besseren Position ist.
Und das ist für GTO oder für Leo-Starts nicht so ganz relevant.
Aber wenn wir dann dazu kommen, Konstellationen zu fliegen oder irgendwelche
interplanetaren Missionen, dann spielt das eine sehr, sehr, sehr große Rolle. Genau.
Weil er dann sozusagen strategisch indiziert wird.
Man startet erstmal, wenn es von den Bedingungen her am besten ist,
dann kreist man vielleicht noch ein, zwei, dreimal um die Erde und muss dann
aber erst diesen Orbit nochmal verlassen durch einen weiteren Raketenschub,
wenn irgendeine planetare Konstellation besser ist.
Das schafft ja auch mehr Flexibilität in den Startzeiträumen.
Also man hat ja auch immer das Ding, was Interplanetaren geht,
da wird sich das Startfenster schon verbreitern, aber jetzt nicht mega signifikant.
Aber man kann halt auch durch eine Wiederzündbarkeit Missionen fliegen und Orbitalplanungen
machen, die vorher einfach nicht drin waren.
Also das ist ein bisschen schwierig zu erklären,
aber es ist zum Beispiel so, dass bestimmte Missionen davon profitieren, performance-mäßig,
wenn man sozusagen unangetrieben einmal um die Erde rum ist und dann das Triebwerk nochmal zu zünden.
Weil man dann an einem anderen Punkt des Orbits ist und dann sozusagen effektiver
diesen Schub nutzen kann. Und bei der Ariane 5 ist es so.
Die Oberstufe brennt und die brennt halt durch. Und dann ist das halt rum und
dann kann ich dann auch keine Optimierung mehr machen.
Und das ist ein Element, was besser ist. Und was auch noch neu ist,
ist die Ariane 5 hatte zwei große Booster und die Ariane 6, die vergleichbar
mit der Ariane 5 ist, wird vier kleinere Booster haben.
Sie kann aber auch nur mit zwei Boostern fliegen, sodass dann die Performance
ungefähr der der Soyuz aus Kourou entspricht, sodass dann die Ariane 6,
wie es ihr Ziel ist, sowohl die Soyuz ersetzen wird, als auch die Ariane 5 ersetzen wird.
Dass der Ersatz der Soyuz momentan noch viel, viel, viel, viel,
viel eminenter und wichtiger ist, da hätte man jetzt irgendwie vor ein paar
Jahren auch nicht drauf wetten wollen,
aber es ist halt ein Element, was wichtig ist,
Weil gerade die Galileo-Satelliten für die Navigation und auch die Sentinel-Satelliten
von der Kommission, was die ganze Erdbeobachtung angeht, aber auch die ganzen
Eumet-Satelliten für die Wetterbeobachtung,
die haben eigentlich auf die Soyuz bzw.
Dann im Ersatz auf die Ariane 62 gesetzt. Und diese Übergangsphase mit der Verzögerung
und jetzt mit dem Wegfall der Soyuz, das hat schon dazu geführt,
dass wir uns auch erkennen,
da sind wir jetzt auch wieder bei der Grundnotwendigkeit der europäischen Raketen,
dass wir jetzt in einer Phase waren, nach dem Überfall der Russen auf die Ukraine,
dass wir keine Startdienstleistungen ausreichend zur Verfügung hatten.
Ariane 5 war ausgebucht, Ariane 6 gab es noch nicht und die Vega-Rakete,
also die kleine Feststoffrakete, kleinere Feststoffrakete ist momentan wegen
technischer Probleme gegroundet, sodass wir momentan aktuell in Europa keine Rakete haben.
Und was ist das Ergebnis?
Wir müssen jetzt in die USA gehen und müssen da Startdienstleistungen einkaufen.
Wie zum Beispiel jetzt mit der Euclid-Mission. Genau.
Und das ist natürlich ein Zustand, der ist nur für eine begrenzte Zeit möglich.
Deswegen ist es gut, dass die 6 rechtzeitig kommt und die erste Mission nach
dem Jungfernflug wird dann auch schon tatsächlich ein Start mit einem institutionellen
Nutzlos aus Frankreich werden.
Also beim ersten Start hat man Sachen genommen, wo es jetzt nicht ganz so schlimm
wäre, wenn es schief geht.
Ja, es gab immer wieder Diskussionen, aber….
Gibt es auch billiger dann in der Regel?
Gibt es eigentlich für einen Selbstkostenpreis normalerweise.
Ja klar, man geht natürlich ein super Risiko damit ein und Risiko wird natürlich
dann auch entsprechend bezahlt.
Okay, das heißt also die Ariane 6 ist im Wesentlichen so ähnlich aufgebaut wie die 5.
Hauptunterschied ist die wieder startbare Oberstufe und dass statt der zwei
Feststoffbooster es eine Konfiguration gibt mit zwei oder vier.
Das heißt je nachdem wie viel Boost man braucht, wie hoch man geht oder wie
schwer die Nutzlast ist, kann man sich das sparen und zwei Booster weniger,
das bringt schon finanziell einen riesigen Unterschied. Ja.
Absolut. Aber damit jetzt die Hörer da jetzt nicht irgendwie auf den falschen
Gedanken kommen und sich dann sagen, ja, dann hätte man ja auch die Ariane 5 nehmen können.
Also das ist die äußeren Ähnlichkeiten und Unterschiede.
Also die wirkliche technologische Weiterentwicklung steckt natürlich im System drin.
Das kann man von außen nicht so richtig einschätzen.
Weil die Ariane 6 ist halt technologisch aus den 2010er Jahren und die Ariane 5 aus den 80er Jahren.
Und da hat sich natürlich viel getan. Da sind wir jetzt wieder zurück bei der
Software und bei der Avionik. Da hat sich natürlich einiges weiterentwickelt.
Das ist komplett ganz andere Architektur.
Aber auch die Produktionsprozesse der Triebwerke sind teilweise neu.
Da kommt jetzt viel mehr 3D-Druck zur Anwendung. Die Materialien der Tanks sind auch neu.
Das war früher nur Aluminium und eine Aluminiumlegierung.
Jetzt hat man da Aluminium-Lithium-Legierungen, die sind viel leichter.
Und generell, also es ist wirklich, also man merkt schon überall,
dass die Zeit nicht stehen geblieben ist und man hat da wirklich überall Sachen
drin und auch die Art, wie die Produktion geplant ist.
Ich hatte am Anfang gesagt, Ariane 5 ist ja so ein bisschen Manufaktur,
und ist Ariane 6 nicht mehr in dem Sinne, dass es tatsächlich nach modernen,
Industrialisierungskonzepten ausgelegt, also mit einer Taktstraße,
die jetzt nicht unbedingt ist wie, wie, keine Ahnung, bei VW in Wolfsburg.
Es ist daran orientiert, wie auch Flugzeuge und sowas gebaut werden.
Also es ist nicht mehr irgendwie, hier steht eine Rakete und dann baut man die
dann so einzeln auf, sondern es ist tatsächlich, an jeder Station wird was gemacht
und wenn es an der Station fertig ist, geht es dann weiter.
Was auch dazu führt, dass die Durchgangszeit von Anfang bis zum Ende der Raketenproduktion
auch geringer geworden ist.
Also wie kann man sich diesen Optimierungsprozess vorstellen? vorstellen.
Also wenn jetzt vorher sehr viel mehr Handarbeit war, dann unterscheidet sich
wahrscheinlich eine Ariane 5 von der nächsten auch erheblich.
Und bei der Ariane 6 ist das dann einheitlicher in der Produktion? Kann man das so sagen?
Das ist bei der Ariane 5 nicht so. Da ist wirklich die Rakete schon ausgesucht auf die Mission.
Und dann zu entscheiden, nee, wir fliegen jetzt lieber Dienstsatelliten zuerst,
das ist gar nicht so einfach gewesen.
Die Produktion selbst, das ist je nach Standort verschieden,
aber kommt auch mit viel weniger Personal aus.
Also die Manufaktur war tatsächlich eine Manufaktur, aber jetzt hat man tatsächlich
viel mehr Industrieroboter und industrielle automatisierte Prozesse,
die zum Einsatz kommen, sodass man,
ich möchte jetzt nicht sagen, nur noch die halb so viele Leute in der Produktion
haben, Aber generell ist es schon eine signifikante Reduktion an den Leuten, die das machen müssen.
Oder machen, ja, machen müssen.
Und sagen wir mal, jetzt geht alles supi mit der Ariane 6, so Bilderbuchstart,
so wie man sich das wünscht.
Die ersten fünf Launches laufen alle tippitoppi ab und alle so,
aha, okay, Europa kann es ja dann doch noch, dann buchen wir mal.
Und jetzt gibt es voll den Run und das Ding wird nachgefragt, wie nix Gutes.
Wie skalierbar ist dann sozusagen sozusagen diese Produktion?
Also ist das das, was du meinst, dass das jetzt sozusagen mehr den industriellen
Prozessen entspricht, dass man dann eben auch so ein Ramp-up machen kann und sagen kann,
okay, jetzt bauen wir einfach sehr viel mehr und kommen jetzt an eine höhere
Taktrate, was ja letzten Endes nicht nur mehr Einnahmen bedeuten würde für die einzelnen Flüge,
sondern ja dann auch bedeuten würde, dass man im Prinzip auch eine Chance hat,
die Produktionskosten als solche zu senken.
Also das geht schon, aber nur bis zu einer bestimmten Grenze.
Also die Anlagen, die wir jetzt alle haben und die Produktionsinfrastruktur,
die wir jetzt haben, die ist darauf ausgelegt, bis maximal elf im Jahr herzustellen.
Und die jetzt geplante Produktionsrate, wir sagen immer im eingeschwungenen Zustand,
Geht von neun aus. Also man hat noch so ein bisschen Luft für zwei,
vielleicht kann man auch mal zwölf herstellen,
aber wenn man jetzt wirklich sagt, okay, die geht wie geschnitten Brot,
wir könnten 20 am Stück verkaufen, dann müsste man tatsächlich nochmal Investitionen
aufbringen, um zusätzliche Produktionsanlagen zu beschaffen.
Das ist eigentlich, also das große Nadelöhr tatsächlich,
sind jetzt gar nicht mal so die Stufen, die wir in Europa bauen,
sondern das ist tatsächlich die Feststoffproduktionsinfrastruktur in französisch-guianer.
Also die Feststoffstufen, die werden in französisch-koreaner direkt gebaut,
hat Sicherheitsaspekte, weil man darf so große beladene Feststoffbooster mit
dem Schiff gar nicht durch die Welt fahren.
Also deswegen hat man sich bei Ariane 5 damals entschlossen,
das in Kourou direkt zu machen und das ist dann halt auch, weil es dann die
Infrastruktur schon gibt, hat man es dann halt da gelassen.
Und wenn man das wollen würde, müsste man da tatsächlich nochmal eine ganze
Menge Geld investieren.
Man müsste auch in Europa Geld investieren, weil wie gesagt die Schweißanlagen
und sowas sind auch ausgelegt auf eine bestimmte Kadenz,
aber das Nadelöhr ist tatsächlich die Produktionskapazität der Feststoffgeschichten in Kuru.
Okay, aber das ist jetzt auch nicht komplett unvorstellbar, dass man das tun könnte.
Man könnte da sicherlich Geld investieren.
Das Interessante ist, da kommen wir jetzt wieder auf deine Frage von der Reusability zurück.
Da ist jetzt die Frage, ob es nicht eventuell tatsächlich mittelfristig schlauer
ist, tatsächlich auf diese Reusable Booster zu gehen.
Anstatt dann viele hundert Millionen in Produktionsinfrastruktur von Feststoff
zusätzlich ranzugehen.
Also das ist dann auch mal so eine Frage, das sind dann Trade-offs,
die wir dann auch machen, zusammen mit der Industrie und zusammen mit der ESA.
Da gibt es keine richtige und keine falsche Antwort. Was wir machen,
das ist ein hochkomplexes System und da gibt es nicht irgendwie die einzig wahre Antwort,
weil das hängt immer davon ab, wovon gehe ich in der Zukunft aus, was sind meine Nutzer,
was ist die Nachfrage,
wie wird sich das entwickeln, wie entwickeln sich Preise für bestimmte Produkte.
Feststoff ist zum Beispiel hochgiftig die Verbrennungsprodukte sind schädlich
für die Atmosphäre, schädlicher als alles andere, was die Rakete von sich gibt,
gibt es da in Zukunft irgendwie einen Drive, dass das aus grünen Gründen nicht
mehr gut ist und nicht mehr akzeptiert ist,
was ich mir vorstellen kann und das sind alles solche Elemente weswegen es immer
relativ einfach die sind ja doof,
die machen das alle ganz nicht so schlau, die beeinflussen, was am Ende dann
die technische Lösung ist.
Von politischen Randbedingungen mal ganz zu schweigen, dass natürlich für die
Industriepolitik in Frankreich eine technische Lösung X vielleicht sinnvoller
ist als Y in Deutschland oder in Italien.
Okay.
Wäre denn außer dieser Feststoffproduktion, gäbe es denn noch andere Bottlenecks
am Standort in Kuru oder ist im Prinzip Kuru auch in der Lage mehr Launches zu machen?
Also man müsste sicherlich, was das Launchpad angeht, auch nochmal erweitern.
Also das jetzige Launchpad, ich weiß es gar nicht, das ist nicht in der Lage
mehr als ein Start pro Monat zu machen.
Warum? Was ist da der limitierende Faktor?
Die Endproduktionshalle, das ist das sogenannte Ball, wo die Rakete aus den
einzelnen Teilen zusammengelegt wird und die Prozesse, die da stattfinden, plus das ELA-4,
also der Startkomplex, für alle Aktivitäten, die du da stattfinden lässt,
brauchst du eine bestimmte Mindestanzahl an Tagen.
Und wenn du die aufrechnest, dann kommst du auf 20 oder sowas.
Und dann brauchst du noch Zeit nach dem Start, um dann wieder zu refurbishen,
weil die Feststoffbooster, die hinterlassen da ja auch durchaus ihre Spuren.
Und so, dass man halt sagt, also unter einer bestimmten Taktrate geht es nicht.
Und wie gesagt, das ist jetzt die Größenordnung.
Wahrscheinlich wird man mit Aktivitäten und wenn man sich anstrengt,
das auch häufiger machen können, aber ich bin mir sicher nicht kontinuierlich jedes Jahr.
Okay, also neben dem Launchpad, diese Halle, das ist sozusagen etwas vorgelagert,
da war ich dann auch, das ist einfach so eine Halle.
Da wird das Ding halt horizontal zusammengebaut, dann rübergefahren und dort erst aufgerichtet.
Das ist ja auch neu, das ist ja bei der Ariane 5, glaube ich,
anders gewesen. Da wird die vertikal transportiert.
Die wird auch vertikal integriert und deswegen sind ja auch die Integrationszahlen
der Ariane 5 so viel höher als, also ich weiß nicht, als du ein Guru warst,
hast du ja bestimmt das Bill und das Buff gesehen.
Das war was, Bill, Buff?
Bill ist das Bâtiment Integration Lanceur. Ja.
Für die 5 oder die 6, meinst du jetzt? Nee, die 5 habe ich leider gar nicht
sehen können. Ich bin nur bei der 6 gewesen.
Also das sind zwei größere, also richtig große Gebäude.
Im Bill wird die Rakete sozusagen, die Unterstufen und sowas zusammengebaut.
Und im Buff, das ist das Bâtiment Assemblage Finale, also das Endmontagegebäude.
Das ist dementsprechend auch noch ein bisschen höher, wo dann auch noch die
Fairing und die Satelliten obendrauf gesetzt werden. Und das wird alles im Vertikalen
gemacht, auf den Starttischen.
Und die Starttische, die rollen dann sozusagen direkt zum ILA-3,
also zum Startplatz für die Ariane 5.
Und der Starttisch der Ariane 6, der ist nicht mehr mobil, der ist fest eingebaut.
Und wie du sagtest, wird die Ariane 6 horizontal da angeliefert und wird dann
erst auf dem Starttisch aufgerichtet, was im Endeffekt genauso ist,
wie es dann auch SpaceX machen oder die Russen.
Okay, das heißt, man müsste im Prinzip, wenn man die Taktrate erhöhen will,
müsste man entweder sich Maßnahmen überlegen, wie man das besser parallelisiert,
weil es wäre ja denkbar, dass man vielleicht in der Halle schon die nächste
zusammenbaut, während die andere noch am Start ist. Das ist ja,
glaube ich, schon weit genug entfernt.
Das war, glaube ich, eine ziemliche Distanz.
Im schlimmsten Fall bräuchte man halt nochmal einen weiteren Startplatz.
Aber das ist tatsächlich ein Luxusproblem. Also da muss man echt sagen,
wenn wir in die Situation kommen, dass wir so viele Ariane 6 verkauft bekommen,
dann ist das tatsächlich ein Luxusproblem.
Aber es ist machbar. Also ich meine, Kuru ist ja ein Rigi-Senn-Ort.
Also das hat mich ja wirklich getroffen wie ein Blitz.
Man steigt da ins Auto und sagt, jetzt fahren wir mal dahin.
Erst mal unterwegs und dann ist man unterwegs und man hat das Gefühl,
man fährt durch das halbe Land.
Das ist einfach ein Riesenkomplex und da ist noch so viel Platz für alles mögliche.
Zumal ja der alte Ariane 5 Launchplatz ist ja jetzt im Prinzip vakant,
oder? Also der wird jetzt für nichts mehr gebraucht, oder?
Der ist momentan vakant, aber der wird Nachnutzung finden.
Also erst jetzt mal übergangsweise wird die Vega wahrscheinlich davon starten,
also die Weiterentwicklung der Vega, also weiterentwickeln.
Die ja derzeit auch noch einen eigenen Startplatz hat.
Die hat einen eigenen Startplatz und der wird auch weiterhin bestehen.
Aber die wird noch weiter entwickelt.
Und um den Startplatz sozusagen an die neue, also wir haben jetzt die Vega ohne Buchstaben.
Ist ausgelaufen. Jetzt gibt es die Vega, also es gibt noch eine Rakete.
Dann gibt es die Vega C, das ist die verbesserte Version. Und dann wird es zukünftig
auch eine Vega E geben. Und die Vega E, dafür muss der Startplatz angepasst werden.
Aber gleichzeitig will man ja die Vega C weiter starten und um sozusagen diese
gegenseitigen Einflüsse zu minimieren,
soll der ehemalige Ariane 5 Startplatz übergangsweise für die Starts von Vega umgebaut werden.
Das ist aber auch erstmal ein Wunsch der Italiener, dem wurde jetzt auch entsprochen, politisch.
Aber wie das jetzt finanziell und mit welchen Inhalten genau aussieht,
da muss man sich mal drüber unterhalten.
Wir sagen, an und für sich kann das keine Dauerlösung sein, weil wenn wir jetzt
wieder auf diese Launcher-Challenge zurückkommen, kann es ja sein,
dass eventuell ein Anbieter einen Bedarf hat, das zu machen.
Genauso sieht Frankreich auch andere Nutzungsmöglichkeiten des ELA-3,
gerade auch wenn man jetzt ein bisschen perspektivischer in die Richtung denkt,
dass man vielleicht auch mal irgendwann bemannte Starts von Kourou aus macht.
Okay. Das Fass wollte ich jetzt eigentlich gar nicht mehr aufmachen.
Das Fass mache ich auch direkt wieder zu.
Okay. Ja, spannend.
Also es geht dann im Laufe dieses Jahres hoffentlich bald los.
Das werden wir dann sehen, wie gut es läuft. Was…,
Liegt denn so jetzt in der unmittelbaren Zukunft?
Also klar, jetzt will man natürlich erstmal, dass Ariane 6 ein Erfolg wird und
man muss halt schauen, wie sich die Konkurrenz, auch die Kostenkonkurrenz mit
anderen Anbietern auf der Welt und SpaceX ist ja noch nicht mal das Einzige.
Also auch in Indien gibt es Launcher-Aktivität.
Für polare Missionen gibt es ja sowieso sehr viele andere Startplätze noch.
Ich glaube auch Japan ist ganz gut unterwegs und irgendeinen habe ich sogar
noch vergessen. mit Chinesen dürfen wir natürlich nicht vergessen,
aber die sind ja nicht so in dem Markt drin und Russland, weiß man nicht,
muss man schauen, wie sich das jetzt entwickelt.
Aber es wird sich ja weiterentwickeln, dieser Markt, ist ja klar.
Was ist sozusagen Beyond Ariane 6 oder ist das jetzt erstmal so das Denkmodell für die nächsten,
Dekaden?
Dekaden glaube ich nicht. Also was klar ist, wo wir jetzt auch die,
also ich in meinem Bereich die meiste Arbeit reinstecken werden,
ist natürlich erst mal die Ariane 6 zum Fliegen zu bekommen.
Und nach dem Erstflug beginnt ja eigentlich erst die richtige harte Arbeit.
Eine Produktionskadenz und eine Startkadenz kontinuierlich so hinzubekommen,
dass wir halt auch ein gutes System haben.
Und dazu gehört jetzt auch, dass momentan die Diskussionen mit der Industrie
am Laufen sind, was die Produktionsverträge angeht in der Industrie.
Ersten Phase der kontinuierlichen Produktion.
Also wir haben zwei Phasen. Wir haben einmal eine sogenannte Transitionsphase,
das sind die ersten 15 Raketen, wo man sozusagen so langsam sich hochfährt und ab Rakete 16,
sagt man, sind wir kontinuierlich drin und da finden momentan Gespräche statt
zwischen ESA, zwischen uns, zwischen Industriellen,
wie diese Phase ausgestaltet wird,
vertraglich und auch auch Randbedingungen, das ist etwas, was auf alle Fälle
jetzt gerade auf dem Papier steht.
Und natürlich ist klar, dass die Ariane 6 bis in die 30er Jahre hinein auf alle
Fälle ihre Rolle spielen wird, wenn es nach mir geht, auch darüber hinaus.
Dann ist aber auch die Vorbereitung der Zukunft ein Element,
was gar nicht so in meinem Bereich hineingehört.
Da kümmert sich ja der Kollege drum, von dem ich am Anfang gesprochen habe.
Aber natürlich habe ich da auch meine Ideen und kriege da auch was von mit.
Wir reden ja auch miteinander. Und da ist natürlich jetzt der erste große Schritt
jetzt diese Ausgestaltung der Randbedingungen für das, was wir diese Launcher Challenge nennen.
Also das ist ja erstmal eine Idee,
aber eine Idee mit bestimmten Umsetzungserwartungen, aber daraus muss man ja
auch erstmal ein Konzept und ein Vorgehen machen, was Hand und Fuß hat.
Und das ist das, was jetzt auch dieses Jahr tatsächlich uns im gesamten Bereich, aber auch der ESA,
sehr viel Arbeit hervorrufen wird, dieses Konzept auch so zu definieren,
dass man 2025 auf einer Ministerratskonferenz auch das entscheiden kann und
sinnvollerweise dann auch mit einem nicht gerade geringen Geldsummen da reingehen kann.
Weil wenn ich Firmen verspreche, dass ich in Zukunft ihre Produkte auf alle
Fälle kaufe, dann muss ich auch dafür sorgen, dass ich auch das Geld habe,
diese Produkte zu kaufen.
Und ich muss ihnen natürlich auch im Rahmen dieser Challenge Co-Financing,
ist das richtige Wort, geben, weil das hat die NASA bei SpaceX ja auch gemacht.
Und diese ganzen Sachen auszudiskutieren, das ist ja, also wie Deutschland sich
das vorstellt, ist das eine.
Frankreich mag es anders sehen, Italien mag es anders sehen,
die Schweiz mag es anders sehen, am Ende muss es die ESA umsetzen.
Und das sozusagen alles so konvergenzmäßig zu haben, dass am Ende alle bereit
sind, bei sowas mitzumachen. Da ist noch eine Menge Arbeit, die vor uns steht.
Aber das ist aus unserer Sicht zumindest ein Weg, mit dem man die Zukunft sicherlich
positiv gestalten kann.
Ja, Dennis. Dann würde ich sagen, können wir an der Stelle auch den Überblick
über das Programm mal zum Ende bringen.
Also Ariane 6 wird kommen.
Derzeit ist noch ein bisschen Flaute in Kuro, aber demnächst kann man sich da
wieder ein bisschen auf Arbeit einstellen. Ich.
Meine, das auf alle Fälle und die ersten 16 Raketen, die sind verkauft.
Also die müssen jetzt nicht irgendwie händeringend nach Kunden suchen gehen.
Also die Raketen sind voll und die Kunden warten, dass es endlich losgeht und
das kann ich verstehen. Also wir warten auch, dass es endlich losgeht.
Ja klar, wir waren alle da drauf. Das heißt, wenn jetzt der Jungfernflug klappt,
geht es dann sofort im Monatszyklus weiter?
Also wenn der Jungfernflug klappt, würde ich prognostizieren,
dass wir mit 24 noch einen Flug haben.
Und dann hängt es davon ab, wie schnell die hoch skalieren können.
Also, es gibt viele Menschen, die momentan nichts anderes tun,
als diesen Ramp-Up darstellen, also nicht zu wollen, sondern sicherzustellen,
dass der Ramp-Up gut funktioniert.
Und da gibt es diverse Planungen mit optimistischen,
mit nominalen und mit pessimistischen Modellen, möchte ich jetzt gar nicht Zahlen
nennen, aber am Ende des Tages wollen wir schon relativ schnell auf diese neun pro Jahr kommen.
Also wir werden 2025 noch nicht 9 pro Jahr haben, das ist auch klar.
Wir werden wahrscheinlich 2026 auch noch nicht 9 haben, aber wenn wir 2027 9
haben, das wäre schon gut.
Okay. Jetzt kann man sich das so etwa vorstellen und dann gibt es regelmäßig
hoffentlich gute Nachrichten aus Co.
Vielleicht habe ich da auch noch mal die Gelegenheit, mir mal was anzuschauen.
Wenn das erstmal läuft, dann denke ich wir auch. Also zum Erstflug möchte möchte
man auf keinen Fall in Kourou sein.
Nee? Sind alle nervös oder was?
Ja, vor allem kriegt man kein Hotel, weil da ist ja jeder da und,
da muss man auch ein bisschen Zeit mitnehmen, weil das wird sowieso nicht an dem Tag fliegen.
Also da muss man auch Geduld haben und Ausdauer. Und da sind dann auch genügend Leute dabei, die...
Aber es ist eine Reise... Es ist ein bisschen heiß, aber das nimmt man damit.
Kourou ist auf alle Fälle eine Reise wert und in einer Raketenstadt,
definitiv. Ich spekuliere lieber auf den zweiten Flug.
Alles klar, Dennis. Vielen Dank.
Ich habe zu danken.
Für die Ausführungen.
Gerne, gerne.
Und dann sehen wir auch mal zu, dass wir hier bei Raumzeit demnächst noch mehr
Aspekte davon abdecken können, aber das war es jetzt erstmal.
Insofern danke ich fürs Zuhören und ich sage Tschüss, bis bald.